SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUB COMMITTEE ONE TO ORDER. N.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WORKHOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE.
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
WE ANTICIPATE ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL BE HERE UP IN THE
CAPITAL I AM JOINED ALREADY BY
SENATOR DAVE MEN AND WE EXPECT
SENATOR OCHO BOGUS. AND THEY'LL
BE NO ROLL CALL THERE'S NO
ACTION ITEMS BUT I WILL NOTE
THE PRESENCE OF CENTER MEN AND
CENTER OF CHAU BROKE WHEN SHE
ARRIVES. OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING AN
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ALSO ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
POLICE SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE. A ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH IS AT THE
END AFTER ISSUE SIX ON THE
AGENDA. OF THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT'LL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. 964-844-2916 THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX OH
NINE THAT'S. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN
SIX OH NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO USE THE
TELECONFERENCES SZTUM. A AND
HOW IT WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE AND OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OR HEARINGS
IN IS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME- LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT THE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE WE
HAVE THREE HOURS FOR THIS
HEARING AND WE ARE HOPING TO
KEEP WITHIN IT. OR AND EARLY.
WHEN JUST. TO BEGIN THE ACTUAL
OVERVIEW HEARING. THIS IS THE
FIRST OF EIGHT HEARINGS OF OUR
REGULAR SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS
TO HEAR THE BUDGET GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND OTHER
RELATED PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUB COMMITTEE
ONE. THESE HEARINGS WILL BE
LARGELY INFORMATIONAL DESIGN TO
ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION OF ISSUES.
AND TO TAKE FEEDBACK TO INFORM
ACTIONS WILL BE TAKEN LATER IN
SUB IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS WHICH WOULD BE IN
APRIL. OR MAY. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING LEVEL
ANNEX EXPENDITURE STRUCTURE. AS
WELL AS SEVERAL PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE. WE WILL
ALSO DISCUSS THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION. AND
FINALLY WILL HEAR AN UPDATE. ON
THE FISCAL HEALTH OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ARE BEFORE WE BEGIN
SENATOR MEANT DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. NO YOU
VERY. SO LET'S GET RIGHT TO
BUSINESS- R. WERE VERY PLEASED
TO HAVE WITH US TODAY. THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION A TONY THURMOND AND
HIS PRESENTATION WILL IN
GENERAL BE ON THE STATE OF
EDUCATION AND IF HE WISHES TO
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ISSUES OF
BEFORE US SO WITH NO FURTHER
ADO LET ME WELCOME
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN WELCOME
TO THE HEARING. WE'RE PLEASED
TO HAVE YOU. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LAYERED MORNING
SENATOR MAN AND WE LOOK FORWARD-
TO- A TROUBLE UP ON- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TO BE A PART OF YOUR
CONVERSATION- AS I. PREPARE MY
ROOM. I AM CONSCIOUS OF THE
FACT. THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
RELEASED THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
MORE THAN THREE MILLION CASES
IN MORE THAN FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES. NEEDLESS TO SAY THAT
THIS MUST BE THE TOUGHEST
EXPERIENCE AND MOST OF US WILL
EXPERIENCE IN OUR LIFETIME. I
WANT TO COMMEND EVERYONE UP FOR
ALL THAT THEY'RE DOING. FOR US
TO BEGIN TO SEE SOME OF THE
SEARCH DECLINING BUT YET WE
KNOW THAT WE ARE STILL IN A
PERIOD WHERE WE MUST
PARTICIPATE THE MOST CAUTIOUS
WAYS I WANT TO COMMEND. OUR
STUDENTS I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT
IT MUST BE LIKE TO I TRY TO
LEARN IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
FOR SURE SAFETY IS A QUESTION
AND SECOND NOT ALL THE TOOLS
EXIST COULD MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED.
LET'S FACE IT OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM WAS NOT BUILT TO DEAL
WITH WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH IT
WAS NOT BUILT TO BE LARGELY
ONLINE AND WE KNOW THAT WE
ESTIMATED MAYBE 70% OF OUR
SCHOOLS ARE IN REMOTE. MODES AT
WHILE MANY OTHERS HAVE FOUND
WAYS TO OLD BRANCH OFTEN IN
HIGH. BUT BUT WE OUR SYSTEM
BUILT FOR ANY OF THIS-
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK THE
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
A TO HIGH SPEED. TEACHERS AND
TRY ON TO REALLY MAKE THEM. OF
DISTANCE LEARNING BUT YEAH WE
FIND OURSELVES DOING JUST THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE AND WE KNOW THAT MANY ARE-
EXPERIENCE A HIGHER RATE OF
DETECTION RISK. BECAUSE OF PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS. AND SO
AGAIN I COMMEND OUR STUDENTS
THEIR EDUCATORS THEIR PARENTS-
FOR THEIR RESILIENCE DURING
THESE TOUGH TIMES- THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED THE PANDEMIC
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED FIRES
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED. MUDSLIDES
THE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN FACT YOU
SO LOS TO. NATURAL DOES- THE-
REYES. THANK YOU OF GEORGE
FLOYD IN A ACTS OF HATE
WATCHING. THOSE WHITES. STORM
MARK. OF THE THREATEN THE PEACE
TRANSFER OF POWER. INTO SEE
INCREASE IN SPITE HATE OUR
STUDENTS ARE WITNESSED ALL OF
THIS THEIR DEAL WITH ALL. AND
THE DIGITAL. THAT WE WILL
STUDENTS GO WITHOUT. IN AND
ACCESS UNIT FOR SOME YEARS HAS
BEEN ON COVER. AS AN
EMBARRASSING FACT CALIFORNIA
AND IN EVERY STATE THIS NATION
WE MY CLOSE DIGITAL DIVIDE. OUR
OFFICE WERE TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE THINGS THIS. OUR SCHOOLS-
ALONG TASK TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL.
WE PROVIDED THAT YOU KNOW OUR
OF THAT OF THE PARTNERSHIP AND
BINARY WITH- TOMORROW WILL HAVE
A- TASK FORCE HEARING FOCUSED
ON. MAJOR SOLUTION TO CALL. THE
DID DIVIDE AND PROTECT BROAD.
CONCERN WE HEAR FROM A NUMBER
OF. OFFICERS ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO THE SENATE YOU
HAVE A PROPOSAL IN A FEW. IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE'VE WORKED A
FULL ON PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH.
STUDENT TASK. AND ALSO PROVIDE
DIRECT WEBINARS FEEL ON A
DRESSING SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEED.
OF OUR STUDENTS ORG- WE HELD
FIELD WIDE WEB IN OUR ABOUT
EDUCATE ON ITS ADDRESS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL. TRANSPORTATION TO
HAVE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ANYTHING THAT'S GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
SO THAT FAMILIES ARE CONNECTED
TO SCHOOL- IN THIS TIME WE KNOW
IT LITERALLY LITERALLY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS. ARE
DISCONNECTED- WE'VE LITERALLY
BEEN ON THE PHONE WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE'RE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS WHO HAVE NOT
CHECKED IN. TO HELP. FIND WAYS
TO GET THEM RECONNECTED IN
SCHOOL SO THAT'S WHERE WE FIND
OURSELVES AS WE REVIEW THIS
BUDGET. THIS IS A GREAT BUDGET-
BUT BY ALL ACCOUNTS IT HAS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
TEACHER DEVELOPMENT WORKFORCE
PREPARATION OF COAL FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO HELP THEM WITH THE
RISING COST. BINDING FOR TO
SCHOOLS UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED
FIVE MILLION THE- ANOTHER
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS WE GONNA
HELP PROGRAM. THIS IS THE HIGH
LEVEL THAT WE HAVE SEEN. WITH
EIGHTY FIVE POINT EIGHTY
BILLION IMPROPER NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS AND SO WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS SICK. BUT WILL MUST
TALK ABOUT. THE PART OF THE
BUDGET THAT DEALS. REOPENING
AND THAT THIS BUDGET AND- TWO
BILLION. A CO TESTS. IN RELATED
MATTERS IT ALSO ENVISIONS-
ANOTHER A BILLION THAT WOULD
DEAL WITH WHAT WE CALL
EXPLORATION OF LEARNING
OSSINING LEARNING GAPS. MORE
PROGRAMS DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
MORE SUPPORT AND OF COURSE
SUMMER PROGRAMS AND SO- WELL
THERE ARE CONCERNS- ABOUT MANY
PARTS OF THE RE OPENING BUDGET-
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CENTERPIECE
IS WHAT SCHOOLS NEED. LET'S
FACE IT GETTING ACCESS TO THE
BACK IS THE GAME TO THAT
ALREADY. NEED AND WITHOUT
ANOTHER DOSES FROM THE
GOVERNMENT WE TERM FOR. TO THE
THING THAT WE CAN MANAGING COLD
TESTING. ROBUST COVERT TESTING
FOR ADULTS AND STUDENTS TO
CREATE A PATH. FOR SCHOOL TO BE
ABLE TO STAY OPEN AND FOR THOSE
THAT ARE NOT OPEN TO BE ABLE TO
RE OPEN. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS WE'VE SPOKEN WITH MANY
OF YOU WE'VE SPOKEN WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES WE SPOKE WITH
SUPERINTENDENTS. AND WE SHARED
FEEDBACK WITH THE GOVERNOR
TOGETHER STAFF I KNOW THAT
GOVERNOR STAFF HAVE BEEN. CAR
WITH THE ASSOCIATE OF SUPER. WE
LABOR LEADERS WITH SUPERINTEND.
AND STAFF TRY AND FIGURE OUT IT
AND LEGISLATORS TO ADDRESS MANY
OF THE CONCERNS AND SO I WOULD
SAY THAT WHILE IT'S NOT
PERFECT. AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ON
DEADLINE IT NEEDS TO BE REVISED
I LEVELS COME. ARE TAKING PLACE-
I WOULD SAY GIVE SCHOOLS WHAT
THEY NEED THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED FOR COVERT TESTING TO
GET OPEN THE KNOW HOW ON HOW TO
DO IT AND HELP. IN MOVE THOSE
RESOURCES BECAUSE LET'S FACE
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE NEVER BEEN
BILL TO PROVIDE COVER TESTING
ON SITE AND WE TO HELP THEM- BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
AND. NEW HOW. TO DO SO- PUT IT
IN A START MORE. THE YOU SEE
CHAIR AND I'D BE. TO A QUICK-
FROM YOU- OR FROM ANY OF THE
MEN OF YOUR TO. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU WE WILL APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND YOU GET
GREAT OVERVIEW OR YOUR TOUCH
ALMOST MAJOR ISSUE THAT IS AN
ISSUE THAT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
AN OF US. AND FRONT OF A LATER
THE BUDGET. AND WHETHER IT'S
BROADBAND OR- LOOKING AT A
OPENING PROPOSED AND- AN I HAVE
TO SAY. FROM A OF RANDOM A
DISTRICT INTO. WE A MAJOR SLIDE
IN MY TO THAT OUT. ONE IN BIG
HANDED IT ISOLATE TO SMALL
SCHOOL DAY. IN STATE TO THE ONE
THAT HAS TO FIVE. TO SOUTH OF
THE MUDS. AND IT IS BEHIND
CLOSURE ON BOTH. SO KNOW THAT
WILL WORK WITH YOU EMERGENCY IF.
TO DEAL WITH. MAKING SURE THAT-
OF THE SERVICES ARE STILL
PROVIDED. SENATOR MEN DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
SUPERINTENDENT- YES- TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE PLEASE. THE
DIFFERENT AND A THAT YOU FOR
YOUR- IN I PRETTY. YOUR
THOUGHTFUL PRO TRYING. THINK
ABOUT THE WHOLE QUESTION OF RIO.
OUR SCHOOL THIS- IN TALKING
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY-
IN DISTRICT I ONE CONCERN THAT
HAS BEEN RAISED TO ME BY A
NUMBER OF THEM IS- IS TO EXTEND
THE SCHOOLS HAVE ALREADY USED.
IT IS SOME OF THE RESERVES. A.
N. CURRENT COSTS AND RE
OPENING. WILL THERE BE ANY
MECHANISMS POTENTIALLY FOR
REIMBURSING THEM FOR THOSE
COSTS I KNOW THAT OPENING IS
PRIORITY- BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE AN INITIAL PLAN WE HAVE A
MECHANISM FOR. MAKING THOSE
SCHOOLS HOLE EVEN IF THEY TAKEN
A LARGE COSTS- TO TRY TO REOPEN.
YES CENTER I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
ENOUGH OF DISTRICTS IN YOUR AIR
THAT HAVE A OPEN AND WORKED TO
STAY OPEN. WE BEHALF TO WORK
WITH THEM ON WHATEVER THEIR
ALLEY. WERE IF THEY'VE ALREADY
USED UP ALL OF THE YOU KNOW
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS ALLOCATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE- AT FOUR- I NUMBER
OF COST WE WOULD THEN LOOK TO
SOME OF THE CURES ACT FUNDING
THAT HAS CARRIED OVER. INTO
THIS YEAR THERE'S SOME TWO
POINT. ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'LL A WEEK AND WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANY OF YOUR
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
UNDERSTAND. WHAT THEIR
REMAINING ALLOCATIONS- AND THEN
IF THEY'VE CONSUMED ALL THAT.
THEN OF COURSE WE RE
ANTICIPATING A NEW STIMULUS
DOLLARS- AND WE ARE GOING
THROUGH WITH THOSE PROJECTIONS.
LIKE AND SO- WE HOPE THAT THEY
CAN USE IN OF THESE FUN. TO
BACK FILL COULD HAVE FRONT LOW.
USING IS A- APPRECIATE THAT YOU.
THANK YOU AND LET ME JUST
FOLLOW UP BRIEFLY BECAUSE OF.
YOU TOUCHED ON AN ISSUE OF CA.
WITH REGARD TO THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS AND- SIX POINT
SIX BILLION THAT IS COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA. BOB HAS A DID YOU
JUST IT INFERRED THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN A REALLY HARD LOOK AT IT
THEN YOU'RE FIGURING OUT
EXACTLY. WHERE IT'S GOING AND
HOW YOU CAN HELP US COORDINATE.
WITH STATE FUNDS THAT ARE IN
THE BUDGET. YEAH ARE OFF DOES
HELP TO. OF THE VARIOUS FEDERAL
THAT COME IN- AND WE WERE CLOSE
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINE. AND IN
TRACKING THAT WILL WE KNOW IS
THAT A VERY. OF EXIST OF THE
ARRAY FIVE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE- THE LOW LAW MEDIC. FUN
THAT WAS FOR COMPUTER.
PROFESSIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM-
SOME DISH STILL HAVE SOME OF MY-
IN SO. AND THEN AGAIN OFFICE
TRACK. FEDERAL MONEY- AND WE-
HELP. PROJECT WHAT THE WE-
BEGIN. FROM THE NUCLEAR FEDERAL
COME OUT- AND- YOU KNOW AND
JUST DAIS HAVE ANY SOME OF THE-
EXACT DOLLAR EIGHT ZERO OVER IN
THIS YEAR. WE CAME INTO THIS
YOU WITH A CO. TWO POINT ONE
BILLION. AND SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
ON A CASE BY CASE BECAUSE WE
TRACK THAT IN. FOR DISTRICTS.
THEM DO SOME PLANNING- TO HELP
THEM- IF THEY HAD DIP INTO THE
RESERVES. NOTHING YOU THAT'S
REALLY HOW. AND HI YOU HAVE A
HARD TO. SO LET ME THANK AGAIN.
A FOR JOINING A TODAY AND WE
LOOK TO WORK. WITH YOU TOGETHER
AS WE DO WITH THESE. AND WE TRY
TO. LAND THE BUDGET NOW AND
JUNE FIFTY. THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN I KNOW THAT YOU HAD
ENGAGE DEEPLY IN THIS CAR.
ABOUT REAL IN OUR- THE TIME
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH YOU- YOU
KNOW SHARED CAN. AND CONCERNS
OF YOUR DISTRICTS- WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF MADE. X.
THAT COMMITMENT TO RETOOL HELD
AS WE OPEN PLAN WILL WORK OUT
SEE WERE A- RED YOU KNOW. WE'RE
WORRIED SO. YEAH WE HAVE TO
AROUND TOWARDS- BUT EVERYONE IS
ENGAGE KIND. LOOKING FOR TO
FIND SOLUTION. AND WE REMAIN
AVAILABLE. MISTER CHAIRMAN BE
HELPFUL THE WE CAN WE
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. WERE
IN THE SAME. AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEE. ON THAT WE WERE
OF. THANK YOU TAKE CARE WE WILL
TO- AND NOW WE'RE GOING MOVE TO
ISSUE TWO WHAT IS THE PROPER
NINE EIGHT OVERVIEW IN
STRUCTURE. WE HAVE TO PAY TO
ADDRESS THIS WE ASK ANY. ERIN
READY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF.
AND CAN CAP AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE AND OFFICE AND- I
SEE THEM ON THE SCREEN SO
THAT'S PERFECT WELCOME TO THE-
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS INTERNET AREA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND TODAY
I'LL BE PRESENTING YOU WITH A
BRIEF BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEES
CALCULATION AND THE K. TWELVE
PACKAGE. THERE IN SPECIFICALLY.
SO COMPARED TO TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT STATE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES AS YOU'VE LIKELY HEARD
HAMMERING REBOUNDED BY QUITE AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT ALMOST
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD- COMPARED
TO WHERE WE THOUGHT THINGS
WOULD BE AT THE BUDGET ACT AND
THAT'S DUE. MOSTLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESSIVE TAX
STRUCTURE ALONG WITH UNFORESEEN
HEALTH OF THE STOCK MARKET AND
CAPITAL GAINS AGAIN ALL
RELATIVE TO WHERE WE THOUGHT
THINGS WOULD BE AT THE BUDGET
ACT- WITH TEST ONE BEING
OPERATIVE IN EACH YEAR THE
GUARANTEE CALCULATION CULTURE
PROBABLY NEED TO RECEIVE. ABOUT
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS ON EVERY
DOLLAR OF AN INCREASE OR
DECREASE THE TO REVENUES PLUS.
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
GUARANTEED. IS OUT ABOUT
SEVENTY NINE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT'S A ONE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
COMPARED TO THE NINETEEN TWENTY
ESTIMATE WE HAD AT THE BUDGET
ACT. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS ABOUT
ELEVEN POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS COMPARED TO THE ENACTED
LEVEL FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
THE BUDGET ACT FOR A TOTAL
AMOUNT OF EIGHTY TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS. THE
INCREASE IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IS ABOUT FOURTEEN POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
ENACTED LEVEL FOR TWENTY ONE
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE EXCUSE
ME- FOR TOTAL MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATION OF EIGHTY FIVE.
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
NOW AT THE BUDGET ACT YOU MAY
RECALL THAT IN RECOGNITION OF
THE EXTREME DROP IN THE
GUARANTEE THAT WE WERE
EXPECTING BECAUSE OF THE DROP
IN REVENUES THAT WAS PROJECTED
AT THE TIME- TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION WAS ADOPTED TO
REQUIRE SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENTS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THAT WOULD BE MADE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS IN EXCESS OF THE
PROPERTY NEED MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATION- AND THOSE PAYMENTS
WOULD BE EQUAL TO ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT OF TOTAL SELL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AND THERE
WOULD ALSO BE. A- TEST ONE
SHARE REVENGE TO BRING THE
SHARE OF- GENERAL FUND REVENUES
THAT GO TOWARDS ROUTE NINETY
EIGHT IN A TEST TWENTY FROM
EIGHT PER. 42% ON AN ONGOING
BASIS CURRENTLY INCREASING THE
TEST ONE CALCULATION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. NOW WITH REVENUE
SIGNIFICANTLY RECOVERED AS I
MENTIONED THE PROBABLY NEED
TRAJECTORY AS MUCH BACK ON A
MUCH HEALTHIER- PASSENGER THEN
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY ANTICIPATED.
THE FOR ELIMINATING MUCH OF
THE- DROP IN FUNDING A
NECESSITY TO THE CAR THE
CONVERSATION AROUND
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE BACK IN JUNE. AND
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING A ONE TIME PAYMENT
INSTEAD IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ONLY AT WITH NO PAYMENTS
NOW YEARS AND ALSO NO- ONGOING
TEST ONE PERCENTAGE REDUCTION
SO THAT PAYMENT INTO. ONE
TWENTY TWO IS EQUAL TO ABOUT
TWO POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN AGAIN THAT'S ONE OF A HALF
PER. OF THE CURRENT. OF CELL
FROM RED. IN THE BY YEAR- AND
WITH A PAYMENT. WOULD IS MADE
ON TOP THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED.
ARE A TOTAL PROPOSED- TWENTY
ONE. NINE EIGHT FUND LEVEL
WOULD BE A EIGHT POINT BILLION
DOLLARS OR INCREASE OF. POINT
TWO BILLION. OVER THE TWO
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR ENACTED
LEVEL AT THE BUDGET. BUILDING
ON TO- SOMETHING CALL THE
PROMENADE RESERVE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT- WHOSE
SCHOOL SYSTEM STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT EXCUSE ME BUT THAT WAS
PART OF PROPOSITION TWO- AND-
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
ARE. ESTIMATING THAT IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THERE ARE
BE DEPOSIT YOUR CHOIR PURSUANT
TO THAT CONSTITUTIONALLY WITHIN
THE PROPOSITION TO- WORTH SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THOUSAND RESULTS OF THIS
IS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ALREADY-
THAT BALANCE OF ABOUT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IS IN EXCESS OF
THE 3% RESERVE BALANCE TRIGGER
SO 3% OF THE PROPOSITION NINETY
TOTAL- IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND ONE THAT RESERVE
BALANCE TRIGGER THRESHOLD IS
MET IT WOULD REQUIRE US SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE OF CAPS TO GO
INTO EFFECT BEGINNING IN.
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THE BUDGET. ALSO
INCLUDES ELEVEN TO DOLLARS IN
CAGE A PORSCHE FOR. THIRTY
MONTHS FEDERAL THROUGH. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS NOW
PROPOSING TO FULLY RETIRE THESE
REFERRALS IN MONTHS JULY
THROUGH NOVEMBER WHICH ON
MONTHS THAT ARE SPECIFIED IN
STATUTE THAT THEY WERE TO BE
RETIRED- AND WE WILL NOT BE
HAVING TO. READ DEFERRED THOSE-
AT AGAIN AND IN THE MONTHS- OF
FEBRUARY THROUGH. JUNE AS WE
WOULD HAVE HAD WE NOT BEEN
PROPOSING TO RETIRE NOW. BUT
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL-
DEFERRAL ESTIMATED CURRENTLY AT
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS FROM FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IN JUNE TWENTY
TWO. TWENTY THREE FOR A NET
BUDGETARY COST IN THE BUDGET
YEAR OF ABOUT SEVEN POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TOTAL NET
PAY DOWN- IN. THE SAVINGS
THAT'S RESULTING. N. F. TO-
PROVIDING WITH. TO SAFELY REACH.
WHEN APPROACHED AND ALSO
DIRECTORIES TOWARDS STUDENTS AT
BY BE MOST ADVERSELY IMPACTED
BY PANDEMIC OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO DOES FROM SIX POINT
SIX BILLION ONE TIME. IMMEDIATE
EARLY ACTION BOZELL AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE AND THESE
PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
IN SOME OTHER COMMITTEES AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE DISCUSSED
AS WELL BUT I DID WANT TO
MENTION THAT- ONGOING COSTS FOR
COAL INCREASES ON THE LCF
ANOTHER CONTROL PROGRAMS EQUAL
ABOUT. TWO POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THERE ARE ALSO
SEVERAL OTHER ADDITION
ADDITIONAL- SPENDING PROPOSALS
THAT WE CAN DISCUSS. LATER ON
IN MORE DETAIL AND HALFPENNY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT- FROM
NARAL ALL AND MAKE COMMENTS
AND- AND LIKE I SAID HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON ANY.
PARTICULAR ISSUES YOU WANT TO
DIVE INTO FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BUT I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE L.
A. O. FIRST AND THEN ASK
QUESTIONS OF BOTH OF YOU WHEN
THAT HAPPENED SO. THEN WE CAN
GO TO A CAN CAP ON FROM THE L.
A. L. WELCOME. TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AND MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN. CAN COUPON WITH THE
END OF THE OFFICE. IN THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE YOU A GOOD.
OF THIS YEAR'S. SO I'LL ADD A
FEW. AND THEN TRY TO OUR CAR.
YES HAVE A HANDOUT. A AND
THAT'S AVAILABLE WEBSITE.
ELADIO THE CA DOCTOR. THE STAR
WITH THE- NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE THE- ARE THE CURRENT
ARE ARE QUITE A- THE ELEVENTH
NINE BILL. IN IN THE TWENTY TWO
ONE GET. REPRESENTS AN IN. OF
SEVEN CHRIS. CAN TO THE
ESTIMATES FROM LAST YEAR. BY A
VERY WIDE MARGIN THAT'S A LARGE
MAN YOU'RE- IN THE HISTORY
PROFITS. NINETY EIGHT. MOST OF
THE NEW PROPOSALS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET ARE RELATED TO
MEETING THAT HIGHER GUARANTEED
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY. THAT
GROWTH CONTINUES IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE GUARANTEE AND-
BY A DENTIST THREE. OVER THERE
OF. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ABOVE
HIGHER CHEN FUND UP. AND GROWTH
AND LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE INCREASE. IN
ADDITION AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MENTIONED THERE'S A TWO
POINT THREE BILLION. A PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS ON TOP OF
THE CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED.
ALL THE OF FINANCE MEANT THAT
BILLION PROPERTY NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE DEPOSIT AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT TRIGGERS
A CAP ON SCHOOL DISTRICT
RESERVES STARTING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THAT CAP IS EQUAL
210% OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
ANNUAL EXPENDITURE IT IS.
BECAUSE THE CAPPING SOUNDS
DISTRICTS OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED OR FEWER STUDENTS THE
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE ARE ACTUALLY ALREADY
EXEMPT FROM THE CAP. BUT BASED
ON THE DATA THAT WE HAVE THE
LATEST DATA FROM EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. WE ESTIMATE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MEDIUM AND
LARGE DISTRICTS OF RESERVES
THAT EXCEED THE 10% CAP.
DISTRICTSMIGHT RESPOND TO THIS
CAPEN VARIOUS WAYS THEY CAN BE
CLASSIFIED TO RESERVES TO AVOID
TO CAP. OR THEY COULD. YOU CAN
EXEMPTION FROM THE COUNTY
OFFICES OFFICES OF EDUCATION WE
THINK THOSE TWO APPROACHES ARE
PROBABLY WHAT MOST DISTRICTS
WILL DO. ALTERNATIVELY THOUGH
THEY COULD CHOOSE TO SPEND DOWN
RESEARCH. AS FAR AS THE
ESTIMATES OF THE I THINK THE
GUY THE ADMINISTRATION PUT
FORWARD IT WAS THE MOST POINT.
OVER THE YEAR PERIOD.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ESTIMATES
ARE VERY TO OUR IS IN TWO BOTH
TERMS OF GENERAL REVENUE. ON
THE PROPERTY TAX. OTHER
ESTIMATES OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE I JUST FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION ABOUT BARS OVER THE
ENTIRE THREE YEAR BUDGET. SO
VERY COSTARS. THANK YOU IN A
SIGNIFICAN ECONOMIC ANSWER.
THIS BASE RIGHT NOW WE ARE
EXPECTING. TO SEE AT LEAST SOME
CHANGES IN REVENUE- BY NAY.
THOSE CHANGES BECAUSE TRUST
FUND IS OPERATIVE WOULD ALSO
AFFECT CARE AND- BUT
SURPRISINGLY THOSE CHANGES IN
THE GUARANTEED MIGHT NOT MEAN
MORE OR LESS FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOLS. THE
EXTENT TO GUARANTEE IS HIGHER
LIKELY THE STATE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE A LARGER DEPOSIT INTO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVES. AND TO THE EXTENT THE
GUARANTEE IS LOWER. THE STATE
IS LIKELY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE AT LEAST SOME OF
THAT DROPPED. BY MAKING A
SMALLER DEPOSITS INTO THE
PROPOSITION AND THE RESEARCH.
ADMINISTRATION ONE ST SOME PAY.
AND WE THAT'S WHERE. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MINIMUM CARE.
AS ARE COVERED GROUND THAT IT
HAD LOST LAST YEAR. AND BARRING
ANOTHER RECESSION IT LOOKS LIKE
GROWTH THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS BE.
ENOUGH TO NOT ONLY COVER THE
COST OF AT BUT I SOME OTHER
AGREED TO. ANOTHER
CONSIDERATION WHICH IS PERHAPS
AN EVEN BIGGER ISSUE FOR THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE IS WELL
THAT THE STATE IS FACED A
GROWING OPERATING DEFICIT ON
THE NON. JUST NINETY EIGHT OF
THE BUT- UNDER THE ADMIN. FOR
THAT DEATH IS GROWS TO NEARLY A
LOT BILLION BY. FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. ABSENT CHANGES THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT THAT
DOUBLES WOULD GO TO NEARLY
SEVEN BUILD WALLS. SO THE
SUPPLEMENT PAYMENT CHANGES. I
DON'T DELIVER THAT DAY. BUT
THEY DO MAKE A LITTLE BIT YOU
TO DO LESS. A SHIFT THIS SPEND
PROPOSED. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAS A TOTAL OF NAY POINT ONE
BILLION YEN NEW PROPER NINETY
SPENDING. I THINK YOU'VE
ALREADY COVER IN THE MID OF THE
MOVING TO. OF THAT NINETEEN
POINT ONE BILLION. POINT FIVE
BILLION IS THE ONE TIME. IN TWO
POINT SIX BILLION IS FOR ON
OBJECTIONS WISELY. JUST ONCE.
WHAT WHAT OTHER ISSUE THE ON
YOUR IS PENSIONS. SCHOOLS AND
CAN COLLEGE BOTH OF EXPERIENCE
LARGE. IN PENSION OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS. THE JUNE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROVIDED TO THREE.
FOR ONE TIME. AT LEAST. SPREAD
ROUGHLY. OVER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AT
THE STATE ESSENTIALLY BY DOWN
COST THE DISTRICTS WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE PAID OUT OF
THEIR LOCAL OPERATING BUDGETS
THOSE TO YEARS. OKAY AHEAD TO
TWENTY ONE TO TWO. DISTRICTS
ARE LIKELY TO FACE AN INCREASE
OF A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS POTENTIALLY AS MUCH AS
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS. THE
INCREASE IS PROJECTED TO BE
MUCH LARGER THAN TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE LIKELY SOMETHING
CLOSER TO ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. AND THAT'S LARGELY THE
RESULT OF THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING- EXPIRING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. ALSO TRYING TO
RSS I THINK ONE KEY ASPECT OF
THIS BUDGET IS THAT IT CONTAINS
A LARGE ONE TIME QUESTION. OF
THE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO A LITTLE OVER FIVE
BILLION HISTORY ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT ONE TIME
QUESTION I GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF PROTECTION. AGAINST
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY REDUCES
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO CUT. I'M GOING PROGRAMS
IS TO GUARANTEE DROPS EITHER
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS
OR POTENTIALLY WITHIN THE NEXT
YEAR TO. ON THE ACT OF PROPOSED
THE FOR POINTS TO BILLION. I
WOULD SUGGEST A SMALLER MORE
TRADED. APPROACH WILL BE
COVERING THAT. WHAT WILL HAPPEN
THE NEXT A PANEL OF THE LATE ON
SO ST MICHAEL ON THE- WE ALSO
WOULD SIX YOU CONSIDER IF YOU
WERE A NEW AND- THIS BUDGET HAS
AROUND TWO DOZEN. THE NEW
PRICKLE ACROSS SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COMBINED.
BUT WE DO THINK SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSALS ARE REASONABLE. BUT
OUR CONCERN IS THAT DOING ALL
OF THOSE PROPOSALS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC MIGHT
DILUTE THEIR INDIVIDUAL IMPACT
AND RISK SHIFTING ATTENTION
AWAY FROM. OTHER RESTORATIONS
COURT PROGRAMS. FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND ALLOCATING MORE
FUNDING FOR PAYING DOWN
DEFERRALS IN ADDRESSING PENSION
COSTS. CAN DOWN DEFERRALS WOULD
HELP- THE STATE'S. GET THE
PROPOSITION EIGHT BUDGET BACK
IN BALANCE THAT WOULD REALIGN
PROGRAMS WITH THE ON GOING
FUNDING THAT IS FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE COULD USE ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SMOOTH OUT THE LARGE
INCREASE IN PENSION COSTS THAT
ARE. PROJECTED FOR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE COULD SET ASIDE EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION NOW ON A ONE
TIME BASIS. AND USE THAT TO
PROVIDE A MUCH MORE. GRADUAL
RAMP UP ATTENTION COST OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS. WE THINK THE
STATE COULD ALSO THINK ABOUT.
PAYING DOWN UNFUNDED. PENSION
LIABILITIES WHICH WOULD REDUCE
DISTRICT COST OVER A MUCH
LONGER PERIOD. YES I CAN OUR
COMMENTS ON THE BUDGET DANCE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- HOWEVER OF QUESTIONS TO
JUST DRAW OUT SOME OF THE
SUBJECTS THAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND THE FIRST ONE WILL
START WITH A FINANCE- YOU
ALLUDED TO IT BUT A GIVEN THE
ONE TIME RESOURCES AVAILABLE
WHY DID DO NOT RECOMMEND FULLY
PAYING OFF THE DIFFERENCE.
RIGHT AND AGAIN AREA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- DOESN'T OF FAIR
QUESTION CERTAINLY SO I THINK.
I WOULD I WOULD. THANKS TO ME I
KIND OF HAVE TO BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT TO KIND OF A HIGHER
LEVEL WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
BUDGET PLANNING WHAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH AND- BUT
SIGNIFICANT YES THE INCREASE OF
FOURTEEN POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS. OR SEVENTEEN POINT TWO
INCLUDING THE- THE
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENT ON TOP OF
THE ENACTED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LEVELS BUT A HUGE PORTION OF
THAT RIGHT HAS TO GO TOWARDS
PAYING DOWN THE DEFERRALS AND
SO DOES LIMIT IN SOME SENSE OF.
HOW MUCH- IN NEW MONEY AS IT
WERE THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
DO BUDGET WITH BECAUSE WE JUST
NEED TO GET. AT LEAST KIND OF
BACK TO THE BASELINE RIGHT
WITHOUT THOSE DEFERRALS AND SO
THAT'S KIND OF HOW I THINK OF
IT AS A SORT OF A STEP. ONE-
AND THEN. MARRYING THAT OF.
WITH THE GETTING GETTING BACK
TO THE DAY. I MEAN. WITH ALSO
TO MAX THE AMOUNT RESOURCES
THAT WE CAN GET OUT TO ELEAZAR.
IN REAL TIME NOW WHEN YOU SEE
THAT THROUGH THE SIX POINT SIX
BILLION IN THE IMMEDIATE ACTION
ON OUR EARLY ACCESS PROPOSALS.
TO REALLY TRY TO MAXIMIZE THE-
LIKE YOU SAID THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCE DIGNITARIES NOW TO
RESPOND WITH THE PANDEMIC TO BE
ABLE TO- RE OPENED SAFELY WHEN
APPROPRIATE TO BE ABLE TO.
BRIDGE THE GAP THAT MANY
STUDENTS ARE FEELING AND
LEARNING THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WHILE ALSO- AS ELIO POINTED OUT
MANAGING THAT CUSHION AS WELL
OF ONE TIME. VERSUS ONGOING
SPENDING PROPOSALS AND SO- THAT
IS WHY WE LANDED ON THE- ALSO
HAVING THE DEFERRAL SO WE ARE
FULLY RETIRING ELEVEN BILLION
THAN CREATING A NEW TO. A NEW
SMALLER TO FOR ALL OF THE THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION WE FELT
THAT THAT WAS. GIVEN THE
CUSHION THAT WE HAVE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO SOME EXTENT
BETWEEN ONE TIME AND ONGOING TO
WHERE. I'VE REVENUES WERE TO
DROP IS ONLY A MENTION OF
BETWEEN- THE- DEEPER MANY
RESERVE DEPOSITS AND OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE- IT
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY MEAN AN
IMMEDIATE CUT. TO WHAT WE HAVE
IN THE BUDGET RIGHT NOW
DEPENDING ON THE MAGNITUDE OF
THAT DECLINE- AND SO WE FELT
THAT IT WAS MOST PRUDENT TO
STRUCTURE IT IN THIS WAY. LIKE
I SAID TO REALLY MAXIMIZE.
IMMEDIATE RESOURCES- AND THEN
ALSO GET- AT LEAST BACK TO A
MORE SIX STABILIZE TRAJECTORY
THAN THEY OTHERWISE. WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THE- THE DEFERRAL AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE THREE POINT
SEVEN AND NOT. JUST AN ESTIMATE
BY- OR INTENT IN THERE IS THAT
THAT WOULD BE WHAT'S CALLED A
JUNE TO JULY DEFERRAL AT THE
END OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR- AND TYPICALLY
THOSE ARE- AND I DON'T THE I
DON'T DOWN PLAY IT TOO MUCH I
DON'T WORK AT DALY LEVELED- AS
FAR AS I UNDER. IT BELIEVE MIKE
FIVE WITH WILL DISCUSSES THE ON
THAT TENDS TO. LESS IN. ON A
CASH FLOW BASIS. GIVEN THAT
IT'S A DEFERRAL OF JUST REALLY
A MATTER. OF WEEKS- THAT AND
WHEN WE HAVE THESE Mà.
FEBRUARY TWO NOVEMBER X. BEING
TO FOR. YOU KNOW CASH FOR
MONTHS MONTHS- SO THAT'S THAT'S
MY OF FOR. IT TO QUESTION.
HOPEFUL I'M NOT GOING TO WITH
FOR FREE AND NOW. OF THE LET ME
ASK A FULL OF COURSE A YEAR
CIRCUM. USUALLY ABOUT ANYTHING
TO THE MEASURE BUT WATCHED SAY.
FEDERAL FUNDS COME FOR
HEALTHCARE AND YOU MAY TAKE TO
BUILD DOLLAR DEAD YOU THINK
WOULD GO TO TEST IT DISSED. BY
FED STATE FUNDS IN SOME WAY ARE
ON HEALTHCARE. BARR AND IT
FREES UP ONE TIME MONIES WOULD
THIS BE NEAR THE TOP OF YOUR
LIST OF SOMETHING TO BUY OUT IN
THE MAY REVISED TO JUST TRY TO
GET IT DONE BECAUSE THEY DID
HAVE EXPERIENCE AS A BUDGET
CHAIR WERE. WHERE PEOPLE WERE
GOING TO ONE TIME DEBTS THAT
ENDED UP LASTING FOREVER AND SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF THAT'S A
PRIORITY. FOR WHEN YOU LOOK AT-
THINGS IN MAY. YEAH WELL I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF.
QUESTIONS WITH WITH IN THAT
BUT- BOTTOM LINE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT IF IT'S A
PRIORITY I THINK AT THAT POINT
IN THE YEAR- THERE'S ALSO THE
QUESTION OF STATE CASH FLOW AND
WHAT HEALTH IS THERE- SO I
THINK IT'S NOT NECESSARILY JUST
A QUESTION OF FEDERAL FUNDS
COMING IN BUT ALSO WHAT'S THE
STATE OF THE GENERAL FUND
REVENUE AND THE AND THE GENERAL
FUND. CASH FLOW PICTURE- AND
AGAIN BY THE TIME ME COMES
AROUND- THERE'S REALLY ONLY ONE
MORE MONTH OF APPORTIONMENT
SITTING THERE AND SO- YOU
REALLY JUST BE TALKING ABOUT
YOU'D POTENTIALLY RESTRUCTURING
THAT END OF THIS YEAR JUNE TO
JULY DEFERRAL- AND WE WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE SOME PAUSE
BECAUSE ANOTHER THING THAT I
DIDN'T ANSWER OR DIDN'T GET TO
IN MY PREVIOUS ANSWER IS- WITH
ELLIE MANY ELEAZAR APPLYING FOR
A TRAN- DO YOU HAVE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE DURING THIS TIME
ALONE- IF. WE WERE TO CHANGE
THE SCHEDULE UP ON THEM- IN THE
MEANTIME MANY OF THEM THEY'RE
THEY'RE APPLYING FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS AT ONCE- ALREADY RIGHT
NOW AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
GETTING APPROVED HERE IF THEY
HAVEN'T ALREADY HERE IN IN THE
FIRST COUPLE WEEKS OF FEBRUARY
AND SO- BUT TO CHANGE UP HOW
THAT STRUCTURE WOULD WORK AND-
DID NOT END UP DEFERRING SOME
OF THOSE MONIES WOULD. RESULT
IN POTENTIALLY- FEDERAL
PENALTIES THERE'S BASED ON THE
TAX STATUS OF THOSE LOANS AND
SO WE'RE A LITTLE HESITANT TO
GO TOO FAR DOWN THAT ROAD- BUT
I THINK- THAT'S FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR DEFERRALS I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT THE DEFERRAL
421-222-2220 THREE- I THINK
CERTAINLY IF A SITUATION AROSE
WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO- SHORTEN
THAT DEFERRAL- YEAH. REDUCE THE
SIZE THAT TO FOR ALL I THINK WE
WOULD BE OPEN TO PRIORITIZING
THAT AS LONG AS WE CAN STILL
LIKE I SAID MAXIMIZE ALL THE
OTHER PRIORITIES THAT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING. TO MAXIMIZE. I
APPRECIATE ANSWER JUST IN IN
THE IN THE- OUT IN THE YEAR OF
THE FOR BUDGET THAT'S- IF MAKE
TOTAL TO NOT RUN UP THE DAY.
BECAUSE ANY TIME. A DISTRICT
THE BALL OR DO A TRAIN ONE OF
THE THINGS PICKING THE IN IN
MANY Y. FOR WHAT THE STATE IS
DOING IN TERMS OF THE DEFERRAL
SO THE SOONER THAT WE CAN BUY
IT OUT IN THE NEXT YEAR. OF THE
BETTER IT IS I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION AND MAYBE I'LL START
WITH THELA- EVEN THOUGH IT
WOULD FIT WITH BOTH OF YOU. AND
THAT IS A SINCE I WAS LAST IN
THE LEGISLATURE PROPOSITION TWO
PASSED AND IT WAS MENTIONED IN
YOUR PRESENTATIONS THAT THE-
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT- IS HERE.
AND MONEY IS BEING SWEPT INTO
IT- IN THIS BUDGET MAYBE IF YOU
COULD TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING IN THAT US
FAR. WHAT IF THE CURRENT TRENDS
WITH WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET
CONTINUE HOW MUCH WILL BE IN
THERE AND- I THINK THAT. NOBODY
THOUGHT THIS WAS GONNA HAPPEN
THIS SOON AND NOW IT'S
HAPPENING AND IT'S ID AND. IF
YOU JUST REMIND OUR LISTENERS.
WHAT THE CITY. IS TO ALLOW YOU
TO GO INTO THE RESERVE AT ANY
TIME SO IT'S BASICALLY WHAT'S
THE STATE OF THE RESERVE BEFORE
THIS YEAR. OF YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THIS LIKE AN- HOUR WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE IS JUST THE START OF A
TREND IN FUTURE YEARS THAT A
LOT MORE WILL GO IN OF REVENUES
CONTINUE IT AT THIS WAY. I JUST
WAS LOOKING FOR A BRIEF
OVERVIEW SO THAT. WE CAN BRING
EVERYBODY ALONG ON THIS. YEAH I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO THAT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE WAS ADDED BY OPPOSITION
TO IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND THE
THEORY BEHIND THIS. PROPOSITION
NINETY RESERVE AS WELL AS THE
STATE'S- BROADER RESERVE THE
BUDGET STATE. ACCOUNT IS THAT
IT WAS DESIGNED TO CAPTURE
UNEXPECTED. SURGES IN ONE TIME
REVENUE. AND SO ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THESE RESERVE
DEPOSIT SEEM LIKE THEY ALWAYS
SNEAK UP ON US IS THAT. THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE RESERVE
DEPOSIT IS DESIGNED TO PICK UP
ITS ONE REVENUE INCREASES IN A
WAY THAT YOU CAN'T REALLY
ANTICIPATE IN A BASELINE
FORECAST. THE FORMULAS REQUIRED
US TO SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING
INDUSTRIES- EVENT IN THIS CASE
THE UNEXPECTED FACTORS THE-
STRONGER CAPITAL GAINS MUCH
STRONGER STOCK MARKET THAN. ANY
OF US ANTICIPATED. LAST SUMMER.
THE PROPOSITION TO WHAT THIS
SPECIAL PROVISION THAT SAID NO
TO PA. INTO THERE WAS COULD IN
TWO HERE AND- ADD- HE WAS GONNA
COME FOR BUT AS THAT YOU'RE HAD
SURPASS. THREE GREATEST LEVELS
ADJUSTED INFLATION AND IT TOOK
A NUMBER OF SAID THAT TO HAPPEN
SO THEY WERE. UP FOR OR FIVE
YEARS THE NAY PASSED WITH
DEPOSITS WERE. BUT AHEAD TO-
FROM THIS POINT I THINK I JUST
DEVICE VERY LIKE ARE POSSIBLE
THE ADMINISTRATION- THEIR MULTI
YEAR- OUTLOOK AS THE
PROPOSITION BALANCE NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY A GOOD. A
GROWING TO THREE BILL BY THE
END OF ONE TO TWO THEN STAY
ROUGHLY AT THREE BILLION OF THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS BUT AGAIN IN
A- GIVEN THE KIND OF FACTORS
THAT FEED INTO THAT CALCULATION
IT COULD EASILY BE MUCH LARGER
MUCH SMALLER THAN THAT OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS. I THINK HE-
RIGHTS OF THE FORMULA LOOK AT.
A GENERALLY THE PROGRESS THE PA
ARE. WHEN THE PROPER NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE. IS GOING FAST
THAN PER CAPITA PERSONAL INCOME
AND WHEN THE STATE RECEIVES. A
LARGE AMOUNTS OF CAPITAL GAINS
REVENUE IN EXCESS OF THE
HISTORICAL AVERAGE ONE OF THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS FROM AND A
TECHNICAL PERSPECTIVE IS THAT.
JUST ONE B. OPERATIVES AND SO
YOU FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MENTIONED EARLIER THAT-
JUST ONE IS OPERATIVE- ALL
THREE YEAR OF THE BUDGET PERIOD.
VERY LIKELY TO BE OFF OF THE
NAY COUPLE OF. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH THE STATE HAS MADE-
RESERVE DEPOSITS IN THE- THIS
IS LIKELY TO BE A DANNY THAT
WILL BE TO ABOUT- FOR YEARS AND
IT'S- AS WELL. I AM WHAT DOES
IT TAKE TO. CREATE TO RELEASE.
MONEY FROM THE- BACK AND THE
STATE BUDGET WHAT'S THAT
PROCESS. THAT IS GOING BY CON.
FORMULAS AND THAT'S REQUIRED.
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE ISN'T GROWING FAST
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT THE PRIOR
YEAR'S FUNDING LEVEL ADJUSTED
FOR. INFLATION FACTOR IN
CHANGES IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE.
SO IF FOR EXAMPLE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WAS A VERY OR YEAR
OR EVEN A- OR A MEDIOCRE YEAR
IN TERMS OF STATE REVENUE IT'S
LIKE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
WITHDRAW SOME OR POTENTIALLY
ALL OF THAT THREE BILLION. IN
ALLOCATE THAT OUT TO SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND A
TIME WHEN THAT HAPPENS THE
LEGISLATURE YOU CAN DECIDE
WHICH PROGRAMS IN WHICH AREA IS
AND HOW THE RESERVE DEPOSIT IS
DISTRIBUTED BACK ON BUT IT'S
BEEN. IT'S BASICALLY LIKE PARA
THE RAINY DAY RESERVE ITSELF IT
IS DESIGNED TO CAPTURE MONEY IN
GOOD TIMES AND BE ABLE TO SPEND
IT IN BAD TIMES TO TRY TO EVEN
OUT THE- THE TROUGHS. IN THE
BUDGET THAT'S THE DESIGN.
THAT'S THE BASIC DESIGN OF.
THE- THE PROPOSITION AND EIGHT
RESERVE A LITTLE BIT RESTRICT
IN TERMS OF WHEN DEPOSITS GO IN
SO WE DON'T MAKE DEPOSITS INTO
THAT ACCOUNT AS OFTEN AS WE DO
FOR THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT. AND ALSO AS MORE.
FORCEFUL IN TERMS OF WHEN THE
POP MONEY HAS TO BE TAKEN OUT
WHICH THE STATE OF LOOK AT MY
DISCRETION ABOUT WHEN IT TAKES
MONEY OUT OF THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT. BUT IN.
IN CERTAIN CASES IT HAS TO TAKE
MONEY OUT OF THE PROPOSITIONING
TO SERVICE. BUT THAT THE J.
IDEA IS SAME. OKAY THANK VERY
MUCH OUR PER THAT AND US
SENATOR MEANT TO QUESTIONS OF
PANEL. YES SO I JUST WANTED TO
I GUESS RE ENTER. CHAIRMAN
LATER ITS POINT OF- WE I TAKE
TO BE THAT THAT WE SHOULD BE
FLOW INCLUDING ABOUT HOW TO
SPEND DOLLARS WERE OBVIOUSLY
FACING. A LOT OF UNIQUE
CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW A. N.
POTENTIALLY A LOT OF ONE TIME
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT COULD HELP
ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS- AND I
GUESS ONE OF THE CONCERNS I'VE
HAD IN AND I KNOW THAT THE
PLURAL OF ANECDOTE IS NOT DATA
BUT- IN TALKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ONLY AS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT. IT'S
CLEAR THAT THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE IN POINT HAS HAS BEEN
REFLECTED PARTICULARLY IN NEED
TO EARLY ACTION ITEMS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTED- AND I
THINK THAT THE L. A. O. HAS
COMMENTED AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THIS LATER THAT THE- EXPANDED
LEARNING AND LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION. PROPOSAL MAY BE
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER LARGE IN AN
APT- AND OF COURSE THERE THERE
ARE SOME. ISSUES THAT BY SMILEY
AS HAVE WITH THE RE OPENING
PROPOSAL IS SO I GUESS I THIS
IS MORE A COMMENT A QUESTION AS
THEY SAY BUT- I THINK
COMMUNICATION WITH THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS CRITICAL. MAKING
SURE THAT SCHOOLS AND THEIR
NEEDS ARE DRIVING OUR BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS PARTICULARLY AS
WERE FACING POTENTIALLY A LOT
OF FEDERAL DOLLARS COMING IN- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO
I GUESS I JUST EMPHASIZE- THAT
THAT HAS BEEN A COMPLAINT FROM
MY DISTRICT. ARE FROM THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT I'VE TALKED TO-
AND THEN I HAD A QUESTION
FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PENSION GAP THAT THAT
SEEMS TO BE A POTENTIALLY
CHRONIC PROBLEM. WHAT ARE WE
DOING AND WHAT CAN WE DO
POTENTIALLY TO INCENTIVIZE
ELEAZAR TO MORE FULLY FUND
THEIR. PENSION LIABILITIES.
THANK TAKE THE FOR. INCIDENT
MAYBE THE PROGRESS IT'S GETTING
ON BY- DESTROY. ADD TO. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HAVE SOME. ABILITY
TO- SAY FOR INCREASES IN
PENSION COSTS THE COST. DOWN
LISTINGS TRUST ACCOUNTS. THE TO
SET ASIDE IN ONE YEAR A COST
INCREASE IN A FEW. BY THEY ALL
REQUIRE TO PAY IN THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT'S- UP AT THE
STATE LEVEL- THE STATE HAS A
FUNDING PLAN FOR CAL STIRS THAT
THE TERM. THE COUNTRY MADE
TODAY TEACHERS ARE TIME SYSTEM
AND THEN THE GUY BOARD OF.
HEALTH THAT'S RATE FOR A
DISTRICT CLASSIFY EMPLOYEES. SO
DISTRICTS DON'T GET TO CONTROL
THE RATE. AND SO THAT'S ONE
REASON AT. THE BIGGEST OF
PENSION AS MUCH OR A- STATE
BUDGETING ISSUE- AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE THAT'S ASIDE SOME
MORE FOR THOSE PENSIONS. TODAY
REALLY HELP MANAGE THOSE GREAT
AND- THAT THEY'RE FACING A YEAR
WILL JUST WILL HAVE TO WHATEVER
YOU WHATEVER THE RATES ARE I
DON'T HAVE TO THOSE. BUT SUCH
ASIDE SO MONEY TO WOULD ALLOW
THOSE GREAT TO GROW BIT MORE
STE OVER THE COUPLE OF. MAKE IT
EASY FOR JUST A TO BOUNCE THE
BUDGET WELL AS THE STATE AND
LOCAL PROGRAMS. THAT GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH. WE REALLY HAVE.
THE BOTH OF YOU BEING WITH
TODAY WAS WERE HELPFUL AND WE
KNOW THIS IS. THIS OF A LONG
SLOW. AND WE'LL BE SEEING YOU
MANY. TO GO SO. THANKS FOR HERE
TO. OR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO A
THREE WHICH TO LOCK CAN FOR
FORMULA AND ARE PAN. OR AGREE
FROM THE- OF FINE. MICHAEL R.
FERRIS FROM THE ALITO'S OFFICE
AND ALLEY GARDNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
DON'T WANT WE START WITH THE- I
ASSUME THAT SELENA RIGHT UP
THERE NOW SO WHEN IT WE START
WITH WIN. YES GOOD MORNING WE
KNOW GRANT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OF TODAY I'LL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW HAVE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FUNDS
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. SO THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT AS YOU
MAY RECALL AND WHICH HAS BEEN
MENTIONED- DID NOT PROVIDE A
STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE LCS BACK IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
AVAILABLE REVENUES. PANDEMIC IN
RECOGNITION OF THE SUSPENDED
CALL UP. AND IN AN EFFORT TO
RETURN LCF AFTER THE TRAJECTORY
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ON. THE CALL
AND NOT BEEN SUSPENDED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FUNDS THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO I'LL SEE
IF THAT'S- WHAT THE CALL OF ONE
POINT 5% BUT IT IS IF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. TWO POINT.
4% HAD BEEN PROVIDED. THIS
CREATES. A COME. COLADA OF
THREE POINT EIGHT PERCENT. THE
JUST TO BE CLEAR- THE BUDGET
DOES NOT RESTORE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALL UP THAT BUILDS
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO LCS. AS
IF I TWO POINT 31% COLA HAD
BEEN PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR. IS COMPOUNDED
COLA IS ALSO PROVIDED TO TARGET
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
AND IT INCREASES THE TOTAL-
QALAT INCREASES ONGOING L. CFM
OF FUNDING BY ALMOST TWO
BILLION- PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. THE TOTAL
DISTRICT LCF FUNDING IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IS PROJECTED TO
BE SIXTY FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION AND THAT FUNDS ALL I
LIAISE AND THEIR FULL LC AFFECT
FORGET LEVEL. THAT'S JUST A
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY AND I CAN
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS UPON
REQUEST OR ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- I CAN REITERATE
ANYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT COLABORA PROVIDING TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUT THAT'S THAT.
THAT'S JUST A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE THAT AND- I THINK
WE HAVE THREE PANELISTS AND
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER WE GET
THROUGH OF ALL THREE. ON NEXT
IS A MICHAEL AFFAIRS FROM THE
ALEJO'S OFFICE. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
FERRIS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE YOU JUST HAVE
A FEW COMMENTS REGARDING THOSE
COLLATERAL CFF WE THINK THAT
FINANCES ESTIMATE- THE ONE
POINT 5% COLOR FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR TO REASONABLE THE STATE
WILL HAVE THE FINAL NUMBER IN
APRIL BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES. WITH THE
ESTIMATE AND THE JANUARY BUDGET.
ON PER THE ADDITION TWO POINT
31% COLA. ADJUSTMENTS HILLS OF
THE WOULD NOT PROVIDE THE KERR
YEAR. YOU TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE- LOST. MORE ONGOING FUNDING
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WOULD BE
MORE MONEY INTO OCF IS A GOOD
WAY TO DO THAT HAS IT. ALL
DISTRICT PROVIDES DISTRICTS
FIXABLE. TO PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR DISADVANTAGED. ON
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH. AND THEN WILL
GO TO SALLY GARNERED- OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU L. A. R. AND BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. WELL WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE A THREE POINT
EIGHT FOUR CALL AN LCS FAST WE
WOULD ASK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
COULD. NOT CONSIDER PROVIDING
THE SAME LEVEL OF COLOR TO THE
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF LCS. I THE
S. S. B. I. HAS NO CREEK. THERE
WOULD BE THAT TERM INCREASE IN.
FIRST TO SAVE OPEN. AND THE
PROGRAMS. OF LCS WITHIN A FROM
THIS ADDITIONAL. AS WELL. IN
ADDITION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THAT HE TRAILER BILL AND
WE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ONCE THAT IS
RELEASED. THOSE ARE REMARKABLY
BRIEF PRESENTATIONS. SO LET ME
FOLLOW UP WITH- A- AWAY FROM
THE STATE'S SCHOOLS CHIEF'S
OFFICE. ARE YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT FUNDING OUTSIDE AT THE
SAME LEVEL. OF FROM. HOME TO
DRAW YOU OUT A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS WHO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AT WHAT
LEVEL OVER WHAT THE GOVERNOR
MIGHT HAVE PROPOSED TO HER.
WHAT WAS THE IMPACT OF WHAT YOU
SAID. CERTAINLY SO I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
KNOW IS THAT THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WILL NOT
RECEIVE THE SUPER COLA AS AS
IT'S BEING CALLED. AND THESE
ARE AREAS IN THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THAT SUPER CALISTA WE WOULD
NOTE THAT SPACE- IT'S SIMILAR
TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED BUT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
FOR THINGS LIKE NUTRITION THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM- ON AN
OTHERWISE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE OUTSIDE OF THE LCF
TRADITIONAL FUNDING MECHANISMS.
OKAY AND LET ME S. FINANCE DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT
NOW THAT YOU'VE HEARD. THAT
PRESENTATION AND THE RESPONSE
TO THE QUESTION. RIGHT I GOT
INTO CONSIDERATION I DON'T KNOW
ERIN GEN. HI I APOLOGIZE
THERE'S A MAYBE A BIT OF A LAG.
GENERATED APART ARMENIANS
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE. OKAY I
THINK EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME NOW-
I WOULD JUST- NOTES IT
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE WE'RE
AWARE OF WE RECOGNIZE- YOU KNOW
ALL OF THAT THE FUNDING OUR
PRIORITIES AND THINGS THAT-
ELLIE WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGED MENTIONED- BUT I LOOK
AT IT AGAIN AS A WITHIN THE
BROADER SCHEME OF THE OF THE
BUDGET PACKAGE TO PROVIDE TO
THE ADDITIONAL COLA TO.
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE THE LCF OUT
MEANS LESS FUNDING FOR OTHER
PROPOSALS PRIORITIES- THAT ARE
ALSO OUTSIDE THE LCF
POTENTIALLY SO IT'S JUST A
CONVERSATION UP WITH IN. IN A
FINITE OF RESEARCH WHERE WE
PRIORITIZE THINGS SO THAT WAS
THE ONES WERE WE WILL AT WHEN
WE DECIDED TO- ONLY PROVIDE THE
COMPOUND COLLEGE THE LCI AFTER-
SO THAT WE COULD- PUT FORTH ALL
PROPOSED THAT YOU IN SIGNATURE
AMOUNTS- AND THE OF SOMETHING
LIKE THREE HUNDRED MILLION OUR
ESPECIALLY. OR INTERVENTION
GRANTS CONTINUATION IT'S
SEVERAL THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A SMALLER AND
PERHAPS LESS SIGNIFICANT IF WE
MADE THE CHOICE TO PROVIDE A
COMPOUNDED CALL OUT TO ALL
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS SO NOT
THEY ARE WITHOUT MERIT
CERTAINLY BUT JUST AGAIN PART
OF THE KIND OF BROADER- BUDGET.
CONSIDERATION AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE ONE WHEN PUTTING FORTH
THAT MUCH KIND IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT THE LEVEL OF REVENUES IS
SUSTAINED WHICH IS HIGHER THAN
THE ESTIMATE AND YOU MIGHT GET
SOME DISPLACEMENT FOR. TESTING
COSTS OR MEDICAL COSTS THAT ARE
IN YOUR PROPOSAL THAT MIGHT
FREE UP MONEY OF FOR THIS AS AS
IT NATURALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEND A THREE DIFFERENT WAYS SO
YOU KNOW WE LOVE TO DIFFERENCE
TO BE PAID OFF WE WOULD LOVE
FOR THE COLD TO BE OUTSIDE BUT
ARM THAT WOULD GIVE YOU
FLEXIBILITY OF SOME OF THOSE
INSTANCES. CAME TO PASS RIGHT.
THIS THIRD. I THINK IT'S YEAH
IF PROBABLY WAS LARGE AND WE
HAVE MORE READ. WERE BE OF IT
AND OF THAT FUNDS BECAUSE I. A
INFLUX OF. EACH FIND AYE AYE
THINK CERTAIN THAT THE
CERTAINLY MAKE OUR JOB A- WE-
COME TOO MUCH WHEN WE HAVE.
MORE MONEY THAN WE KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH SO YEAH THINK. THAT
THAT'S A REASON TO- APPROACH TO
HAVE- I DON'T KNOW I'VE HEARD.
COMPLAIN THEY SAID MONEY. SOME
PROBLEM I SUPPOSE YEAH. MMHM
AND HE ONE THING AND DON'T KNOW
BEST DO THIS MAY I JUST WITH
THE- A. O. THEN GO- EITHER WAY.
BOMB ARE. EVERYTHING'S MOVING
TO WILL WE HAVE THIS TO. RIGHT
NOW TALKING WHAT TO DO IS MY BE
BUT NOW AND MAY. BY JUST. WATCH
RECOMMENDED- YOU HAVE ANY SENSE
OF WHAT COLE WAS MIGHT START TO
LOOK LIKE IN THE OUT YEARS SO I
MEAN R. D. WHEN YOU START THAT
DISCUSSION- WITH SCHOOLS. WHO
WHAT COULD YOU TELL THEM BASED
ON WHAT YOU KNOW NOW. SO I
DON'T KNOW BUT I REALLY DON'T
WANT TO TAKE THIS OR I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE IT AS WELL- MAYBE IF I
COULD HAVE MY COLLEAGUES CAN.
BEGUN THIS. YEAH THANK YOU
CHAIR CABANA DALLAS AUSTIN SO.
PROJECT IN A COLA HAS- BEEN A
LITTLE BUT A EXERCISE IT'S-
COMES TO US. FROM A FEDERAL AND
THAT'S DESIGNED TO REFLECT
REFLECT THE COST OF. ATTENDANCE
PURCHASED BY STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT'S THE NOW IS A GREAT
MEASURE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA- ARTICLE ESTIMATES
COME FROM- THE CONSENSUS
FORECAST THAT'S PREPARED BY
MOODY'S ANALYTICS. AND THEY
HAVE THE COLA HOVERING AT
AROUND ONE AND A HALF PERCENT.
PER YEAR OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS SO THAT IS A BIT LOWER
THAN WHAT DISTRICTS ARE USED TO
THE AVERAGE HAS BEEN AROUND TWO
AND A HALF PERCENT OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS. OR SO- SO
THEY IS A I THINK IT CAN. FOR
YOU AT THAT THERE MIGHT. AN FOR
DE. TO MY THESE RELATIVE STILL.
OR MODEST. COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS THE NEXT YEARS JUST
KIND OF THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
CUT A OF ME AS COVERED A BIT.
FROM WHERE IT WAS IN JUNE BUT
WE'RE PROJECT BUT- AT A LOT OF.
ARE SLOWER IN COUPLE OF.
REFINED I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A HIGHER ASK COVERING
CLOSER TO PER. OVER THE COUPLE
YEARS- I'D IT'S A TO- INDEX TO
BRIDGE THE GAP- SO THAT BUT I
THINK THAT WE AND A HALF TO.
PERCENT THAT'S KIND GOOD
PLANNING RANGE FOR A DISTRICTS
AND STATE TO OF THE COUPLE. I
YOU I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR AND I
KNOW. WHEN L. A. O. SAYS QUOTE
IT WOULD BE A DE ACTORS AND
SOME MORE IN SOME WAYS TO. LA
SPEAK FOR TO CRACK. AND WILL
JUST SEE WHAT WITH THESE FOR
GOING UP IN DOWN MY SENATE MEN
DO YOU HAVE ANY. NO HE GOOD SO
WHAT BUT ME JUST THANK OF YOU-
REALLY APPRECIATE- ARE YOU.
HERE A I KNOW THE- THAT SOME OF
YOUR- BECAUSE- IT SEEMS LIKE
SAID EXPO. BECAUSE THE
DIFFERENT. SO GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER. WHICH IS THE FOR
STATE FOR. AND THE PATH WE HAVE.
IS MELISSA NG FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
ELLIE GARNER AGAIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND WE
HAVE AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SO. NOW LET'S GO IN THAT ORDER
MELISSA ELLIE AMYMORE SIFANG
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE- I'M LISTENING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF SINCE I JOINED HAS
ALREADY DONE- NUMBER GOOD JOB
IN LAYING- THE AMOUNT OF TIME
FUNDS WE RECEIVE SO FAR AS WELL
AS- YOU KNOW WHAT THE FUNDING.
BEEN SO FAR- SO JUST TO GO
QUICKLY OVER THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FUNDING THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ALLOCATED SIX POINT
FOUR BILLION. AND ONE TIME
FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS AID RELIEF
AND ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT OR
CARES ACT OF FUNDING FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION THIS INCLUDED
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION FROM
THE CORONAVIRUS RELIEF FUND- R.
C. R. F. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE POINT TWO MILLION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY EDUCATION
RELIEF FUND. WORK YEAR AND ONE
POINT SIX BILLION FROM THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND OR ESR.
THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION IN
CRF ALONG WITH THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION FROM TWO YEAR AND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION PROVIDED
FROM PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUND PROVIDED TOGETHER AT TOTAL
OF FIVE POINT THREE BILLION.
FOR LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION.
THIS FUNDING WAS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS VARIOUS IN. AND TO CALL
THE NINE- INCLUDE- FOUR PP. I'M
HEALTH AND SAFETY ACT
ACTIVITIES EXPANDING LEARNING
SUPPORTS INCREASING
INSTRUCTIONAL TIMEFOR DEVICES
AND CONNECTIVITY- INTEGRATED
STUDENT SUPPORTS AND ADDRESSING
OTHER BARRIERS INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDS
PROVIDED FOR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION ONE POINT SIX
BILLION WAS PROVIDED FROM
ANSWER WHICH ALSO ALLOW FOR A
BROAD RANGE OF BOTH OF USES
FROM ADDRESSING LEARNING LOSS
TO PREPARING SCHOOLS FOR RE
OPENING. 90% OR ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION WAS ALLOCATED AT LEAST
BASED ON THEIR PROPORTION OF
CHILD ONE PART EIGHT
ALLOCATIONS WHAT THE REMAINING
10% OF THE FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
AN INCREASE IN THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR SCHOOL
MEALS. A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS MODEL AND FRIEND
MINISTRY AND COST FOR
ALLOCATING IN OVERSEEING THE
CURES ACT FUNDING- MOVING ON TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE MOST
RECENT CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE AND
RELIEF SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS ACT OR CHRIS US.
SIGNED INTO LAW LATE DECEMBER
PROVIDED SIX POINT SEVEN
BILLION FOR SECOND ROUND OF THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
RELIEF FUND WHICH WE CALL AS
OUR TWO. BEST FUNDING HAS
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS AS S. R.
ONE IN THAT 90% OF THIS FUNDING
OR SIX BILLION BE ALLOCATED TO
ELEAZAR BASED ON THE PROPORTION
OF TITLE ONE PAR AID
ALLOCATIONS. THE STATE DOES NOT
HAVE DISCRETION HOW THIS
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED OR THE USE
OF THESE FUNDS CENSUS. AND
SPECIFIED IN FEDERAL LAW. SO DO
TO TIE THE GOVERNOR'S MUCH DID
NOT THE PER. FOR THE FUNDING
FROM THE SECOND- FOR BELIEF
PACKAGE HOWEVER WE DID SUBMIT A
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT LETTER TO
ALLOCATE THE SIX BILLION AND
ONE TIME ANSWER TO FUNDS TO
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE NEEDS. OF
SCHOOLS NO OF THE REMAINING.
FLEXIBLE FUNDS FROM ANSWER TO
THE 10% OR SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION. WE
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE PROPOSALS
FOR BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
A PLAN FOR THE FOR THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS. ADDITIONALLY THREE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE MILLION IS
AVAILABLE FROM THE SECOND ROUND
OF GOVERNORS- REGENCY EDUCATION
FUND OR HERE TO. OF WHICH A
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION IS
FLEXIBLE WELL ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION IS TO
SUPPORT THE EMERGENCY AID FOR
NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AGAIN FOR
THE FLEXIBLE FUNDS WE INTEND TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON A PLAN. FOR THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS. AND THE
LAST POINT I WANTED TO MENTION
IS THE SPENDING DEADLINE FOR
THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION IN
SIERRA PROVIDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE ARE PROPOSING AS
PART OF THE IMMEDIATE ACTION
PACKAGE- TRAILER BILL TO EXTEND
THE SPENDING DEADLINE FROM
DECEMBER. THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TO MAY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE FEDERAL
DEADLINE WAS EXTENDED UNTIL.
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- HELLO WE PROPOSED
AT LEAST. AY UNSPENT FUNDS
JUNE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ALLOW FOR BOTH- TIME TO RECOUP
AND REALLOCATE FUNDS IF ANY-
WE'RE HOPEFUL THE L. A.'S WILL
FULLY EXPAND THEIR ALLOCATION
PRIOR TO THIS NEW DEADLINE.
HOWEVER WE INCLUDE THIS
LANGUAGE AS A CONTINGENCY AND
TO ENSURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE LIMIT.
RETURNING UNSPENT FUNDS FEDERAL-
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL HAVE QUESTIONS
I'M SURE BUT WE WILL DO IT
AFTER- WE HEAR FROM THE OTHER
TWO PANELISTS. OUR NEXT IS L.
A. GARDNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A OF. IS COVERED BY SOURCES
AVAILABLE AND TO KEEP MY
REMARKS BRIEF. JUST GONNA DIVE
RIGHT INTO WHAT CDP HAS SEEN IN
TERMS OF EXPENDITURES AND USES
OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS. THE CDC
COMPLETED THE THIRD QUARTERLY
REPORTING CYCLE IN JANUARY FOR
THESE FUNDS WHICH CAPTURED
EXPENDITURES FROM MARCH FIRST
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT DATA REFLECTED 99%
OF THE C. R. FUNDS WHICH MAKE
UP ABOUT 83% OF AVAILABLE ALOT
EL AL AND FUNDING. AND SO 99%
OF THE C. R. FUNDS ARE EITHER
EXPENDED ARE OBLIGATED TO THIS
POINT. FURTHERMORE THE DATA
REFLECTED THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THE C. R. FUNDS ABOUT 59% WERE
USED FOR DISTANCE LEARNING. AND
THAT INCLUDES THINGS LIKE.
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
IMPROVEMENTS SUCH AS INCREASING
BROADBAND CAPACITY. SOFTWARE
PURCHASES THAT ENABLE DISTANCE
LEARNING HARDWARE PURCHASES FOR
STUDENTS AND OUR TEACHERS SUCH
AS LAPTOPS AND TABLETS.
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS FOR
NECESSARY DISTANCE LEARNING.
AND STAFF TRAINING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NECESSARY. TO
PROVIDE QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING. FOR THE REMAINING
FIVE WERE TRYING THE GEAR ASSUR
IN GENERAL. AT SOURCES. THERE'S
A LARGE OF MONEY AND XP FUNDS.
RANGING FROM A LOW OF 72% THE
GENERAL REMAINING TO HOW OF
EIGHTY NINE FOR OF THE STILL
ROOM. HOW I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS
IN LINE WITH CITIES
EXPECTATIONS FOR USES OF FUNDS.
ALLEYS WERE VERY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED TO SPEND THEIR C. R.
FUND ALLOCATIONS FIRST GIVEN
THAT THE ORIGINAL DEADLINE FOR
USING THESE FUNDS WAS DECEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY. WELL
GENERAL FUND HAS AN EXPIRATION
DATE OF THIS YEAR JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
YEAR AND AS A FUNDS DON'T
EXPIRE. UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WE ARE IN. OF CALL
DATA THE FIRST. REQUIRED ANNUAL
REPORT FOR ASSET YES SIR AND
YOUR EXPENDITURES THOSE COVER
THE MARCH THIRTEENTH STREET
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TIME
LINES. IT'LL IT ALIGNS WITH THE
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR. AND WE
WILL HAVE MORE DATA SHARE ON
THOSE FUNDS ONCE THAT REPORTING
CYCLE HASBEEN COMPLETED. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THEN EMILY FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WELCOME IN MORNING
SENATORS AMY LEE FROM THE L. A.
L. SO I WILL JUST FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THE SECOND FEDERAL
RELIEF PACKAGE THAT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTH. THIS PACKAGE PROVIDES
A TOTAL OF EIGHTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. RECEIVE ABOUT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
ITS PUBLIC KEY TWELVE SCHOOLS.
MOST OF THE SPENDING SIX
BILLION WILL BE PROVIDED
DIRECTLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
AFTER TWO FUNDS WHICH WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. DISTRICTS
CAN USE THESE FUNDS ON A
VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL OPERATIONS. AND
WILL JUST NOTED THAT THESE
ALLOWABLE USES OVERLAP WITH
THOSE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWO BILLION FOR SCHOOL
WE OPENING AND- FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION FOR EXTENDED LEARNING.
THEIR MEANING EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION CAN USE ON
STATE RIGHT PRIORITIES IN
RESPONSE TO COPE AT NINETEEN.
OF THIS. SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE MILLION COMES FROM
ASTOR AND THE REMAINING ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR MILLION
COMES FROM GEAR. TO GEAR MONEY
CAN BE USED ON EITHER K. TWELVE
OR HIGHER EDUCATION. THE MOST
NOTABLE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
CARERS ACT AND THE SECOND TIME
A FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGE IS
THAT THE SECOND PACKAGE ALSO
PROVIDES. ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
EMERGENCY RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
CITY HAS SIX MONTHS TO WORK
THESE FUNDS ELIGIBLE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND ANY FUNDS REMAINING
AFTER THIS TIME. CAN BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR STATE RIGHT
PRIORITIES AS CARE FUNDING. IN
ADDITION TO THESE FEDERAL FUNDS
THE BINDING AND MANY. HAS SEEN
INTEREST IN PROVIDING. FUNDING
TO SCHOOLS THE PLAN WOULD
PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. WHICH AN ESTIMATED
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT FOR IT SEE
SCHOOL RE OPENING DISTANCE
LEARNING AND LEARNING RECOVERY.
I'M HAPPY TO. CONCLUDE MAY BE
MORE AND ANSWER ANY QUESTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH. I
HAVE A CUP OF. IN THE FIRST ONE
IS- OF FURTHER REPRESENTATIVE
FIND. ARE YOU MENTION THAT ON
FLEX FUN THAT COME FROM. OF
FEDERAL STEM. THAT YOU WORK THE
LARGER. ON AIDS I THINK THE SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION
IS WHAT YOU REFERENCED. AND
WORK ON A PROPOSAL WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT YOUR TIME
FRAME ON THAT WHEN ARE YOU
EXPECTING TO DO THAT. LISTING
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
SO WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH THE SPRING YOU
KNOW AS- DEPARTMENT HAD
MENTIONED THESE. THE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO AWARD WITHIN-
WITHIN ONE YEAR SO WE HAVE
UNTIL DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO. I'M KIND OF PROGRAM
THESE FUNDS AND WILL HAVE UNTIL
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TO SPEND A FUNDING. SO I THINK
WE HAVE YOU KNOW TIME IN THE
SPRING TO KIND OF WORK THROUGH.
THE PRIORITIES BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. AND YOU DON'T
THINK THAT MAYBE SOME OF THE
URGENCY OF THE PANDEMIC MIGHT
REQUIRE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SOONER. CANCELLABLE FUNDING
WE'VE- ALLOCATED. THE BILL- ITS
ACTION TO EIGHT WE ALL HAVE OUR
PROPOSAL FOR THE BILL. AS WELL
SO POINTS BILLION- YOU KNOW
THESE REMAIN FINE. UP WE DO
FORWARD TO. NOTE TRYING TO-
TARGET THOSE FOR IT. SINCE
WE'VE WE ARE. THESE LAW- HOT
FUNDING FOR- A LOT OF THE REST.
THE COMPANY PANDEMIC IN
ALLOWABLE. FROM NO SCHOOL RE
OPENING TO YOU KNOW. IN A- WITH
THAT YOU KNOW THIS. REMAINING
FUNDS WE COULD COULD YOU FOR
MORE. FOR BUT BUT IT IS THERE
FOR TURNS OUT THAT THERE'S DEAL
TO BE MADE ABOUT REAL AND EDIT
MY FIT SOME WAY. IS THAT STILL
WHAT THAT STORE. HAVE RECOMMEND.
TO IF THAT WERE THE- YES WE
WILL BUILD TO ARKANSAS. THIS AS
PART OF THE PACKAGE IS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
AND THEN MY QUESTION IS FOR THE
LARGEST AND- ARE YOU SAID IN
YOUR COMMENTS THAT THERE WAS AN
OVERLAP OR WITH THE STIMULUS
MONEY AND SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE PROPOSED. DID
YOU HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS OR
DIRECTIONS TO LOOK AT THAT
OVERLAP AND SEE IF THERE WAS
ANYTHING YOU THOUGHT WE SHOULD
DO DIFFERENTLY AND HOW THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE IMPLEMENTED. I
MEAN WE WITHOUT A. AGAIN SO
DON'T HAVE ANY. RECOMMENDATION
FOR HOW FAST YOU CAN LEVERAGE
THEIR SIX DOLLAR WILL BE. THEIR
US TO I THINK OUR WE WOULD ONLY
LET. TO CONSIDER HOW THESE FUN
HE BE USED IN CONCERT WITH A
PROPOSED ON THAT. REALLY TO USE
RE OPENING ACT ANNEX EARNING.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
CENTER MINUTES HE HAS AN
QUESTIONS OF PANEL YEAH I HAVE
A FEW. I GUESS I APOLOGIZE FOR.
IS THE L. A. AND PARTNER A
FINANCE. I DIDN'T SEE- ANY
DISCUSS- HEARING TO. OF IS PER.
IN A CO- STIMULUS PACKAGE BEING
NEGOTIATED NOW BETWEEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND CON. ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDS
THERE THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
MIGHT ALSO IMPACT- THIS BUDGET
DISCUSSION. YES SENATOR I DO I
CAN THAT IN WITHOUT OKAY. I'M
SO AS AS FOR AS WE'RE- THAT DAY
PUT OUT THE ANIMATION TO
PADDOCK PLANNED TO. JUST
FUNDING TO. ON IT WOULD A
HUNDRED AND BILLION ACROSS. THE
NATION AND AN ESTIMATE THIRTEEN
BILLION WOULD GO TO CAL. TO
SUPPORT CAL SCHOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY SEEMS LIKE AT
THAT AT THE FOR A LEVEL
DISCUSSIONS ARE STILL. AND IN
TERMS OF THE FOR AMOUNT WILL BE
FOR- CAL. AND WHATEVER TRY TO
RELIEF LOOKS LIKE I THINK IT'S
A BIT TO EARLY TO. RIGHT NOW IF
IT ASSUME WE GOT SAY LIKE ONE
TEN OF THAT- THIRTEEN BILLION.
HOW WOULD THAT IN. THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET- DISCUSS IN A
AND WHAT MIGHT BE SORT OF.
CHANGE. IF ANYTHING. AND MAYBE
THAT'S FOR THE PART OF FINANCE
LIKE ANYBODY WE THIRTEEN WE'RE
NOT THAT WERE FLEX IN USE WITH
THAT CHAIN ANY OF PARTICULAR-
PRIORITIES THAT YOU HAVE IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. YES WHAT IF I
SO CERTAIN OF WE RECEIVE THE
FOR- BE CONSENT WE WOULD
CONSIDER. YOU KNOW AS WE OUR
THE OWN YOU KNOW THE TWO ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. I THINK AT
THIS TIME IT'S A LITTLE. FOR US
TO MAKE ANY ASSUMPTIONS AND-
YOU KNOW THAT HASN'T PASSED AND
YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF STRINGS MAY BE ATTACHED
TO HOW MUCH DISCRETION THE
STATE WILL HAVE YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH WILL BE. ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBLE USE AND YOU KNOW THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INTENDS
TO HAVE NO RESPONSE BE MORE
TARGETED SINCE THEY'VE ALREADY
PROVIDED. OF FUNDS TO ANSWER TO
AND YOU KNOW DEAR TO AS PART OF
THE LIKE CARISSA THAT WAS
PASSED IN DECEMBER. GOT IT. SO
I GUESS MY SECOND QUESTION
RELATES TO THE ANSWER TO FUNDS
WHICH I UNDERSTAND- ARE. I TO
BE ALLOCATED BASED ON TITLE ONE
GUIDELINES- GIVEN THE CORONA
VIRUS HAS IMPACTED ALL
STUDENTS- SHOULD THE STATE BE
THINKING ABOUT ALLOCATING FUNDS
TO HELP. THOSE DISTRICTS SUCH
AS MANY WITHIN MY DISTRICT
WHICH WILL RECEIVE A LOT LESS
FUNDING UNDER THE TITLE ONE
STRICTURES THAT ACCOMPANIED.
THE ANSWER TO FUNDS. LIKE IN
OTHER WORDS THE STATE TRYING TO
UP THE- SINCE- ALLOWED THESE
DAYS WILL BE- RECEIVING A LESS
FUN. PLUS A ONE BERMAN UP. SO
YES WE DID COULDN'T THAT SINCE-
THIS IS WHY WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
A PROBLEM NINETY ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR THE BILLION FOR A REAL. AS
WELL SUPPORT SIX BILLION IS
COMP TO THE FEDERAL ARE BEING
PROVIDED SINCE THE ARE OF THE-
YOU KNOW THE TO BE. IS OF A TO.
ELIGIBLE L. A. YOU KNOW APPLY
BY SPECIFIC TIME FOR. AND MEET
THE REAL. WOULD RECEIVE A
SCREEN- AS WELL AS THE POINTS
BILLION- IT IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
ELEAZAR. SO YOU KNOW IT TO THE
EXTENT THAT SCHOOLS. DON'T GET
A PIECE OF THAT FOR ALL FUNDS
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO AT LEAST
ACCESS SOME RESOURCES FROM
STATE FUNDS. GOT IT AND A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON THE
ANSWER TO FUNDS AND I THINK
THIS IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE SUPERINTENDENT'S
OFFICE- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THESE ARE VERY VERY
FLEXIBLE IN HOW THEY CAN BE
USED. DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF
HOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WHAT WHAT
THEY'VE TOLD YOU AS FAR AS
THEIR INTENTIONS FOR THEIR.
USAGES OF THIS MONEY. YES SO. I
BELIEVE DEPARTMENT HAD
MENTIONED THIS EARLIER THAT.
THE BULK OF THE FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION THAT WAS
ALLOCATED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
A LOT HASGONE TOWARDS- YEAH.
BUILDING THE DISTANCE LEARNING
STRUCTURE- THESE WERE FOR COSTS
THAT WERE INCURRED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
WHERE. YOU KNOW MANY SCHOOLS
HAD TO PIVOT AND KIND OF YOU
KNOW. UP UP PROVIDE ALL IT
BEAST LIKE TECHNO. TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGY TO THEIR SCHOOLS AND
OTHER STUDENTS AND COMPUTING
DEVICES CONNECTIVITY- SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO SEE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT. WHAT THE NEW USES WILL
BE- WE DON'T HAVE ALL THAT DATA
WE ONLY HAVE DATA FROM THE C.
R. F. SO FAR SINCE THAT WAS THE
SHORTEST TIME PERIOD BUT- YOU
KNOW WE INTEND THAT SCHOOLS
WILL START USING THIS NEW
FUNDING FOR ON SCHOOL RE
OPENING- ACTIVITIES AND- REALLY
TARGETING FOR ACADEMIC
INTERVENTION AND- HELPING CLOSE
THE GAPS AND- CATCH STUDENTS
UP. THAT AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
FALLING BEHIND. OKAY AND THEN
SO I GUESS MY FOLKS IS. YOU
KNOW IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE USING FOR BUT SOME OF
THEM MIGHT USE IT FOR SCHOOL RE
OPENING SOME OF THEM MIGHT USE
THESE FUNDS FOR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION- THIS PLEASE A
LITTLE BIT IN THE NEXT TOPIC
AND ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
RE OPENING PROPOSAL BUT- DOES
IT MAKE SENSE TO PUSH FORWARD
EARLY ACTION ITEMS THAT
ALLOCATE. A HUGE AMOUNT OF PROP
NINETY FUNDING FOR THESE
PURPOSES. WHEN WE HAVE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT THAT MANY SCHOOLS
MIGHT END UP USING. THAT
FUNDING FOR THE SAME PURPOSE.
RIGHT SO I THINK SCHOOL ARE
NOW. THERE ARE AT. LEVELS OF
YOU KNOW RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC AND IN THERE YOU KNOW
PROCESS FOR RE OPENING. SOME
ARE STILL KIND OF IN THE EARLY
STAGES WILLARD THEY'RE STILL
TRYING TO MEET THE BASIC NEEDS
OF THEIR STUDENTS- YOU KNOW
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS AND YOU
KNOW. TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS
TO CONTINUE LEARNING SO WE
DON'T WANT TO. RESTRICT THE
FUNDING IN THAT WAY AND YOU
KNOW TRY TO DO A- A BLANKET.
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO USE IT
FOR WE KNOW THAT THERE'S LIKE
VARYING LEVELS OF- YOU KNOW
WHERE THIS SCHOOLS ARE IN IN
THEIR PLANS FOR RE OPENING SO.
I THINK WE'RE JUST WE'RE TRYING
TO KEEP IT. AS FLEXIBLE AS
POSSIBLE SO SCHOOLS CAN RESPOND
TO- YOU KNOW ALL THE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES. BUT THE MAY BE
FACING. RIGHT THANK YOU. LET ME
THANK THIS PANEL. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS THAT
WAS REALLY HELPFUL. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
FIVE WHICH IS THE- EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME AND ECONOMIC
INTERVENTION GRANTS A SENATOR
MEN SAID SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
HAS. BLED INTO THIS IN THE
PANEL IS GOING TO LOOK FAMILIAR
TO US IT'S GOING TO BE MELISSA
ANG FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MICHAEL OF FED US FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IN AND WE GARNER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WILL GO ON THAT ORDER BEGINNING
WITH MELISSA ANG. WELCOME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ARE
SAYING WITH DEPARTMENT OF. I'LL
TO HIGHLIGHT MAIN POINTS OF
THIS PROPOSAL SINCE THEY CHEN
HAS ALREADY- LAID OUT THE
DETAILS- SO AS PART OF THE
MEDIA ACTION PACKAGE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROPOSING
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION FOR THE
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME AND
ACADEMIC INTERVENTIONS GRANT-
ELIGIBLE ELEAZAR WOULD RECEIVE.
ONE THOUSAND PER HOMELESS
PEOPLE AND THE STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS WOULD RECEIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE- WITH
THE REMAINING FUNDS ALLOCATED
PROPORTIONALLY ON THE BASIS OF
LCF STAFF TO BE ALLOCATED EQUAL
PORTIONS- IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FUNDS ARE INTENDED
BE USED FOR ACTIVITY THAT WOULD
SUPPORT ON ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
INCLUDING EXPANDING
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. AND
PROVIDING TARGETED ECONOMIC
INTERVENTIONS- WITH PRIORITY
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS FOSTER AND
HOMELESS YOUTH. AND STUDENT
WITH STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AS WELL AS PEOPLE'S IDENTIFIED
FOR YOUR READING ENJOYMENT
STRATEGIES. EXTEND- A- LEN WITH
ALSO BE REQUIRED TO INCLUDE AN
ADDENDUM TO THE L. CAPPED
PROVIDE A DESCRIPTION OF A PLAN
FOR ASSESSING NEEDS OF ITS
STUDENTS AND FOR EXPAND.
EXPANDED LEARNING AND ECONOMIC
INTERVENTION OPPORTUNITIES-
THIS EXPENDITURE PLAN WOULD- WE
NEED TO DETAIL HOW THEY WOULD.
AN EX FOR. X. FOR A OF THE
ALLOW PURPOSE WITHOUT X. TO BE
A- WHEN IT IS A- AND WITH THAT-
FOR I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
THANK THANK YOU MUCH AND AS
WITH THE PANELS WERE. TAKE THE
QUEST ONCE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
THE SPEAKERS OR MOVE TO SPEAKER
NUMBER TWO MICHAEL R. FERRIS.
OF. FROM THE ALEJO'S OFFICE
WELCOME BY. THANK YOU MICHAEL.
BUT THE L. A. O. SAYS THE OF
FINANCE FROM THE DETAILS OF THE
PER. OR JUST TURN TO OUR- OUR
WILL TO KNOW THE INTERESTS OF
AS PER. WE ARE TAKING INTO A
THE SIX DOLLAR AND ONE FEDERAL
THAT WAS JUST DISCUSS IN THE
PRE PANEL. COMBINED WITH THE
AND S. TO FIND TO GO PROPOSED
WOULD PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH TEN
SIX BILLION DOLLAR IN THE THIRD
ONCE FUNDING. THAT WE NEED TO
BE SPENT BY THE END OF TWENTY
ONE TWO. WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
IS MORE THAN THE STATE SPEND ON
ALL ITS FOR. PLUS ELSE YOU. WE
HAVE A FEW CONCERN A GROUP SUCH
LARGE AMOUNT OF ONE TIME IS.
SCHOOLS IN ONE YEAR. FIRST
GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTY REGARDING
SOME REAL. SCHOOLS MAY HAVE
DIFFICULT PLANNING AND SUCH A
AMOUNT OF FUNDING OVER ONE YEAR.
THIS IS PART THE CASE FOR ITS
ARE- REQUIRE HIGHER. TO OR-
INTERVIEWS ON TO THE. THANK IF
THE ARE UNABLE TO PLAN FOR A
LARGE OF NOWHERE. THEY MAY USE
IT. FIVE TO COVER COSTS TECH.
THAT THEY ARE PLANTS CONDUCT.
THIS COULD RESULT IN NO AND
BENEFITS IS. THIRD THEIR FACTS
OF THE CASE. ON LEARNING AND
WILL BE ARE NOT LIKELY TO SIX.
AFTER WHEN YOU. FUNDING COULD
PROVIDE BETTER TO SEE IF WAS
SPENT ON ACT. OF ACTIVE OR- YOU.
AND NOW TO SPEAK ARKAN WITH
THEM OF FUNDING WE DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE BENEFITS
PROVIDING. ADDITIONAL STATE FOR.
MOST SINCE THE FED FUNDING A
AND CAN BE YOU FOR THE SAME
ACTIVITY INCLUDE IN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING COULD BE YOU TO AND
SCHOOL TO COME THAT TO THAT
WOULD HAVE GREATEST BENEFIT
FIRST. AND ARE TIED LEGISLATE
PRIORITY. PARTICULAR WE THINK
THE LIST MEANWHILE TO INCUR
SCHOOL TO OUR ACTED. ENRICHMENT
THIS SUMMER THAT WOULD BRING
STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL. AND
ALLOW THE TO ENTER WITH SCHOOL
STAFF AND THEIR PEERS- ALLOWS
SCHOOL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES STUDENTS WITHOUT THEM.
WITH EXTRA AND- OF. THAT
STUDENTS TO BEGIN WITH DURING
YEAR. PROVIDING THE SERVICES
PERSON WOULD HELP AVOID THE
WITH FACE WITH LEARNING FROM
ALL. IN LINE WITH OUR SYSTEM
THE PROPOSED HE RICK THE LET'S
PROVIDE US AMOUNT A ONE TIME
FUNDING TO JUST THIRTY LOS
USING THIS. HELLO METHOD I
PROPOSE BY THE GOVERNOR THROUGH
THIS THE RALLY A LC OF. WE WERE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE FULL OF THIS ONE
FUNDING TO INQUIRE SCHOOLS
OFFER. THIS GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF
SIX FUNDING BILL. WE THINK THAT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
IS A RE. AMOUNT OF FOR THE- OF
THIS AMOUNT. WE SUGGEST ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BE THERE FOR A
ACT. IN ACTIVITIES. WE
RECOMMEND A- SCHOOLS TO EXPEL
THE FUNDS BY THE TWO TWENTY
ONE. AND THAT ACTIVITIES MUST
PLACE DURING IN USING AN
INCREASE OR I MODEL. SO THE
EXTENT OF THE- UNDER STATE AND
PULLED HEALTH OR. FOR THE
REMAINING FIVE MILLION. THAT WE
SUGGEST. I RECKON THAT THE
FUNDS WOULD FOR IN ACT. DURING
THIS YEAR SO AS INCREASING AS
TIME WORK BUT ADDITIONAL THE
NEW COURSE OF SERVICE. WE ALSO
ALLOWING THESE TO USE OVER A
TWO YEAR PERIOD SO ALLOWED TO
SPREAD OUT THE SERVICES FOR US
TO. OVER A LONGER OF TIME.
FINALLY IN REGARDS FOR YOU TO
FUNDING THERE RESULTS PROVIDING
SMALL AMOUNT THAN WHAT THE GUY
PROPOSED. AND I WOULD MY CAN
CALL. CALLED SORRY CALLING CAN.
DISCUSS EARLIER. WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LET'S TO RECTIFY.
THE REMAINING FIVE FOR HIS
PROPOSED TO FURTHER PAY DOWN.
THE STATE'S ON SENDING TO. AND
ADDRESS SCHOOL DO AND COSTING.
IS AN ARGUMENT. IMPROVE SCHOOL
RESILIENCY. IS THAT WOULD
CREATE MORE. THE FOR SCHOOL TO.
AND HELP THEM SYSTEM THE
PROGRAM OVER TIME. THIS
CONCLUDES OUR COM AND HABITS
AND ANY. AT PREVIOUSLY WE MUST
FOCUS ON ACCELERATED LEARNING
FOR STUDENTS WHOSE FAMILIES
WERE HARDEST HIT BY THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WE NEED LEARNING
EXPLORATION PROGRAMS
INVESTMENTS EXPANDED LEARNING
ACADEMIC COACHING. EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
BURKE MORE RESOURCES TO HELP
RECONNECT HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN REACHED FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL YEAR. WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS AS THEY
HAVE BEEN INELIGIBLE FOR OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING THUS FAR
INCLUDING RECENT FEDERAL FUNDS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION FURTHER ON ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND ARE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BOB I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS AND SOME OF THEM
HAVE BEEN ANSWERED IT IT IN
EFFECT IN THE PREVIOUS. BOB
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE OF THE
INTERACTION OF- OF FEDERAL AND
STATE. BUT I WAS GONNA ASK
FINANCE. IF YOU HAD ANY
RESPONSE. TO THE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT. A CHUNK OF
THESE FUNDS. ARE BEING MOVED
INTO SUMMER PROGRAMS GIVEN.
IMPART HOW LONG IT'S TAKEN TO
ACT ON SOME OF THE EARLY
ACTIONS AND SECOND WAVE THAT
THERE WERE FEDERAL STIMULUS
FUNDS THAT SHOWED UP- DO YOU
HAVE ANY RESPONSE ON THE- FAR
AWAY OWES RECOMMENDATION TO
SPEND MORE ON SUMMER PROGRAMS.
CERTAINLY SOME LISTENING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO YOU
KNOW THESE FUNDS ARE LARGELY
FLEXIBLE SO THEY WOULD BE YOU
KNOW ELIGIBLE TO USE FOR SUMMER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WE DO THINK
THERE SUFFICIENT NEED- RIGHT
FOR SCHOOL SEEK FOR THIS
FUNDING- YOU KNOW THIS DOESN'T.
KNOW PROVIDING THIS ONE TIME
FUNDS DOESN'T- NO PRECLUDE US
FROM PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AS NEEDED IN FUTURE YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD ADD THANK
YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
US ABOUT THAT MR FERRIS. YEAH I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO- WHY NOT
THAT THE ONE OF THE BENEFITS
THAT WE SEE ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING WOULD BE TO JUST
ENCOURAGE CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
SINCE THE SPECS OF THE FUNDING
IS SO FLEXIBLE. AND CAN BE USED
FOR THE SAME PURPOSES OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THIS WOULD JUST
BE TO ENCOURAGE SOME ACTIVITIES
THAT WE THINK WE HAVE THE
GREATEST BENEFIT FOR STUDENTS
AND ARE TIED TO. THE
LEGISLATURE OKAY WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND ALSO I HAVE TO ASK YOU
REALLY DIRECT QUESTION EVERY
TIME YOU LEAN TO ONE SIDE AND
MAKE A COMMENT HI WHAT APPEARS
TO BE LA FROM LA SPORTS TEAM
SEEMS TO JUMP OUT FROM BEHIND
YOU RESPECT TO WHAT'S GOING ON
BACK THERE. YEAH I'M FROM THE
US AND CALIFORNIA ALSO A CO.
OWNER CAL. GRANT WEALTH. THAT'S
TRUE L. A. R. BOUNCE THE NORTH
WITH THE SOUTH DON'T TAKE A
FIRM POSITION IN. EITHER WHITE
WALL WELL THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION. CENTER
MEN DO YOU HAVE BEEN. SENATOR
MINUTES GOOD SO WHAT. LET ME
THANK- ALL OF YOU FOR THAT. OF
A PANEL ARE WE APPRECIATED AND
I KNOW. SOME OF THE REPEATS AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
FOR US. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THE- OF SIX THAN LAST ISSUE OF
WHICH IS FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THE PANEL
CONSISTS OF ONE PERSON I MIGHT
FIND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFER
OFFICER OF THE- FISCAL CRISIS
AND MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAM
AND LET ME JUST SAY. AS MR FINE
COMES UP THAT- I KNOW THIS WILL
PROBABLY TAKE A LITTLE LONGER
THAN THE OTHER PRESENTATIONS
BUT ALSO. THAT ONE I LOOKED AT
HIS PACKAGE- IT LAUNCHED RIGHT
INTO THE CHARTS OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE HAPPENING OR DISTRICTS
ARE HAVING FISCAL PROBLEMS. AND
THE AGENDA PACKET PROVIDES A
GOOD BACKGROUND ON SORT OF THE
HISTORY OF HOW WE'VE GOTTEN
HERE SO THE TWO FIFTY GATHER.
SO MR PHONE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF MY PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU- THIS MORNING AS-
SINCE- YOUR NEW IN YOUR ROLES-
I'LL GIVE YOU JUST A SHORT
BACKGROUND ON- THE FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM ALTHOUGH YOUR-
AGENDA PACKET DOES A GREAT JOB
ABOUT MONEY NOW WE ARE CREATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WE ARE A COMPONENT
PART OF THE OVERALL FISCAL
OVERSIGHT PROCESS. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT PROCESS REALLY
IS FOCUSED WITH COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS MR
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- WE WORK
CLOSELY. ON A DAILY BASIS- WITH
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE
DA- ACROSS THE STATE WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BUT ALSO WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU HAVE- IF
YOU. HAVE THIS MORNING- BERMAN
OF EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OF.
LEGISLATIVE PANEL OFFICE
CONTROLLERS OFFICE AND WE DO
THAT ON A VARIETY OF- OF TOPICS
BOTH OPERATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
TOPICS THAT IMPACT- OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES- STAFF
REPORT INDICATES THAT WE SPEND
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE SPEND
ABOUT 90% OF OUR TIME ASSISTING
DISTRICTS THAT ARE PROACTIVE IN
REACHING OUT TO US FOR
ASSISTANCE IN ONLY ABOUT 10% OF
OUR TIME ON FISCAL DISTRESS-
WELL THAT'S TRUE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT ALSO TO BREAK DOWN
THE NINETY PERCENT. ACTUALLY
IT'S ABOUT 70% WERE OF OUR TIME
IS SPENT ON DISTRICTS THAT IT
REACH OUT TO US AND ASKED FOR
ASSISTANCE IN SOME REGARD- WE
WILL ASSEMBLE A TEAM OF EXPERTS
FROM OUR STAFF IN SYMPTOMS
RETURNED. OUTSIDE OF OUR STAFF.
TO ASSEMBLE A TEAM TO GO INTO A
DISTRICT CAN ADDRESS THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE. ARE THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR HELP ON-
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF THE TIME
IT'S FISCAL RELATED BUDGET
RELATED LONG TERM FINANCIAL
PLANNING- OF WRITING OF THIS
TOPICS WE WILL OUR- TAKE ON
ALMOST ANY TOPIC. INCLUDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION
TRANSPORTATION FOOD SERVICE OUR-
THE BOARD STAFFING HOW HOW THE
DISTRICT IS ORGANIZED IN THIS
IT'S STAFFED APPROPRIATELY. TO
MEET THEIR MISSION AND SO ON.
ABOUT 10% OF OUR TIME IS SPENT
ON PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WE
CONSIDER THAT TO BE. ABSOLUTELY
A LINCHPIN IN KEY TO AVOIDING
FISCAL DISTRESS THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE JOB THEY'RE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. WRONG AND SO TO
THAT END WE- CONDUCT A NUMBER
OF US A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ON OUR OWN
BUT WE ALSO PARTNER WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AND OTHER PRIVATE
COMPANIES EVEN. TO DELIVER-
BRIDIE OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTERS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITHIN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ROUND
UP ARE THE DEVELOPMENT OF TOOLS
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF SOFTWARE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE FREE OF CHARGE TO THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY. BY JUST
DOWNLOADING THEM FROM OUR WEB
PAGE THESE INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
THE LCF CALCULATOR WHICH THE
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATEIT'S THE TOOL
THEY USED TO ACTUALLY CALCULATE
THEIR LCF REVENUES WE HAVE A
PRODUCT CALLED PROJECTION PRO-
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS USED TO
DO MULTI YEAR FINANCIAL
PLANNING CASH MANAGEMENT. AND.
CASH FORECASTING AS WELL. BUT
TEMPERS OF OUR TIME IS SPENT ON-
A ALEX. OF MISTER. OF PUBLIC
FUNDS. COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
HAVE THE AUTHORITY- TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
AND USUALLY NOT ALWAYS BUT
USUALLY WHEN THEY ELECT TO DO
SO THEY TURNED TO US ABOUT
THREE QUARTERS OF OUR STAFF-
HAVE FRAUD- A CERTIFIED FRAUD
EXAMINER- CERTIFICATIONS AND
EXPERIENCE- SO WE'RE ABLE TO A
SYSTEM. IN IN THAT WORK AND
THEN IS THE STAFF REPORT
INDICATES ABOUT 10% OF OUR TIME
IS SPENT ON FISCAL DISTRESS AND
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS R. EIGHT
WHAT WE CALL THE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED. SYSTEM OF OVERSIGHT
WORKS ACTUALLY VERY VERY WELL-
THIRTY ALMOST THIRTY YEARS
SINCE WE HAVE IN PLACE I WOULD
HAVE NINE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT
REQUIRED EMERGENCY PREPARATION
IN AT THIRTY YEARS AND I THINK
THAT'S TESTAMENT TO THE WORK
OUR COUNTY OFFICES OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S. OFFICE IN IN THE
COLLECTIVE GROUP OF REALLY ALL
OF US- THE IMPACT THAT DEATH SO
THAT WE HAVE IN ASSISTING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ONE LAST
NOTICE THE STAFF REPORT
INDICATES THAT ARE PART OF OUR
ORGANIZATION IS ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL INFORMATION
SERVICES- THE BASE THERE IN
SACRAMENTO- THIS IS A- LARGE
SCALE SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT-
OPERATION OF BUSINESS ANALYST
REQUIREMENTS ANALYSTS AND
PROGRAMMERS AND SOFTWARE
ENGINEERS. QUALITY ASSURANCE
TESTERS AND HELPED US PEOPLE
AND WE ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WITH A VARIETY OF
DATA MANAGEMENT NEEDS FOR DATA
RELATED TO STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS AND ALSO ALSO
FINANCIAL COLLECTION DATA ALONG
WITH A. NUMBER OF OTHER-
CONSIDER. IN SO WHEN TURN YOUR-
TO THE PROCESS OR TO A REAL
WHAT WE'RE HERE ABOUT AND HOW
IS OF THE FISCAL STATUS OF OUR
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
JUST TO REMIND YOU THE
PROCESSES THAT EACH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST ADOPTED
BUDGET INSTRUMENT THAT BUDGET
TO EITHER BE KEPT THEIR COUNTY
OFFICE OR TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION BY JULY
FIRST THOSE TO OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES THEN DO A REVIEW AND
BY MID SEPTEMBER- THEY HAVE A
CHOICE OF EITHER APPROVING.
APPROVING WITH CONDITIONS OR
DISAPPROVING THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S BUDGET. SO THE FIRST
THING THAT I WOULD REPORT ON IS
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR A WE HAVE
ONE DISTRICT WITH A DISAPPROVED
BUDGET ONE OF THE ELEVEN
CURTAIN. FIFTY YEARS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- AND THAT PARTICULAR
DISTRICT- THIS IS THEIR- THIRD
CONSECUTIVE DISAPPROVE BUDGET
ARM THAT WOULD BE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED. THE NEXT UP
PROCESS RELATED TO OVERSIGHT-
IN THERE ARE THEIR NUMBER STEPS
IN THE ANNUAL OVERSIGHT PROCESS
BUT THE NEXT RELATED TO CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET. IS WHAT'S CALLED
THE FIRST IN A REPORT IT'S THE
FIRST OF TWO. IN A REPORTS THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PREPARING
AGAIN SUBMIT TO THEIR COUNTY
OFFICE ORDERED THE STATE
DEPARTMENT- FOR- REVIEW AND
CONSIDERATION THESE ARE-
UPDATES TO THEIR BUDGET BASED
ON A NEW ASSUMPTIONS NEW
INFORMATION. SUCH AS ENROLLMENT
IN IN AND SO ON THE FIRST ONE
IS BASED ON DATA THROUGH
OCTOBER AND IS DUE BY DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH I'LL BE REPORTING ON
THAT TODAY BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
MOST RECENT DATA. THE SECOND
ONE IS DATA AS OF THE END OF
JANUARY- AND IS REPORTED BY THE
FIFTEENTH MARCH- IT SHOULD GIVE
YOU A- QUICK OVERVIEW- AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ANY DETAIL
QUESTIONS BUT A QUICK OVERVIEW
OF THE DECEMBER FIRST IN
REPORTS. WE HAVE FIFTY ONE
DISTRICTS FALL QUALIFY ONE LET
ME BACK UP A SECOND I'M SORRY
STRUCTURE- COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT HAVE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ROLE WITH THEIR
GUARDIAN REPORTS THAN BUDGET A
BUDGET AS INDICATED THE
APPROVED. WITH CONDITIONS ARE
DISAPPROVING IN REPORTING- THE
DISTRICTS SELF CERTIFY A STATUS
IN THAT STATUS IS EITHER
POSITIVE QUALIFIED OR NEGATIVE
POSITIVE IS THAT THINGS ARE IN
GOOD SHAPE FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
AND SUBSEQUENT TWO YEARS WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT A THREE YEAR
WINDOW. BECAUSE PART OF THIS
OVERSIGHT SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
DESIGNED AROUND CONCEPTS AROUND
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM SO WE WANT
TO BE LOOKING OUT- DISTRICTS
MAY CERTIFY QUALIFIED WHICH
MEANS THEY MAY NOT MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS IN THE
CURRENT OR TWO SUBSEQUENT YEARS
OR NEGATIVE WHICH MEANS THEY
WOULD NOT BE THERE. ARE THEIR
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS IN THE
CURRENT QUARTER. ONE SUBSEQUENT
YEAR. AND SO AT FIRST IN A
REPORT. HI WE HAVE FIFTY ONE
SERVE QUALIFY. DISTRICTS ARE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME COUNTY
OFFICES IN THE REVIEW PROCESS
DID NOT CHANGE ANY OF THOSE
COUNTY OFFICE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE AUTHORITY TO
WHAT WE CALL DOWNGRADE
DISTRICTS SUBMITTED POSITIVE
THEY COULD DOWNGRADE TO
QUALIFIED IF THEY SUBMITTED
QUALIFIED THEY COULD DOWNGRADE
THEM TO NEGATIVE WE HAD NO
DOWNGRADES ALL FIFTY ONE OR
SELF CERT. FIFTEEN ARM OF THESE
FIFTY ONE THIS IS THEIR THIRD.
OR MORE CONSECUTIVE QUALIFIED
IN SO LITTLE DEEPER LOOK IN
JUST THE TOTAL NUMBER- AND HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN IN THAT STATUS.
FOR MORE THAN A FOR THREE OR
MORE TIMES. THREE OF THOSE
FIFTEEN HAVE BEEN IN THE
QUALIFIED STATUS FOR SEVEN OR
MORE REPORTING PERIODS THOSE
INCLUDE ALLAN ROCK UNION
ELEMENTARY IN SANTA CLARA GOAL
TRAIL ELEMENTARY IN ELDORADO IN
OAKLAND UNIFIED IN ALAMEDA. WE
ALSO HAD THREE AT FIRST INTERIM
THREE NEGATIVE SELF
CERTIFICATIONS ARE TO OUR
CONTINUING ONE IS A SACRAMENTO
CITY ARE CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
BUDGET DISAPPROVAL THE SECOND
IS A SMALL DISTRICT BELL RIDGE.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
KERN COUNTY- AND IN THE CASE OF
BELL RICH- THERE'S NO
INTERVENTION BEING PROVIDED
THERE CURRENTLY- AT THE LASTS
UP GOING TO THE LAST STEPS OF
THE PROCESS RELAXATION WHICH
MEANS THE C. STORE OPERATORS AT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN A
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT WILL TAKE
THEM OVER THEY'VE LOST SUCH
SIGNIFICANT. ENROLLMENT DUE TO
A NEIGHBOR'S- SCHOOL THAT-
THEY'RE SIMPLY GOING TO CEASE
OUR WHAT WE CALL LAPSED ONE NEW
ONE DISTRICT IS NEW TO THE
NEGATIVE SIR CATION AND THAT IS
TO- GROVE UNIFIED IN
SACRAMENTO- SPECIFIC TO ELK
GROVE A LARGE DISTRICTS SIMILAR
TO SACRAMENTO CITY. OF BILLION
UP GROUP'S CASE SO LONG HISTORY
OF A WELL MANAGED DISTRICT
STRONG RESERVES. THEY HAVE A
SUDDEN SHIFT OF ENROLLMENT THAT
WE BELIEVE IS ONE TIME IN
NATURE DUE TO THE PANDEMIC- ARM
AND THEY WERE ALSO AT FIRST
INTERNATIONAL ARE ALL DISTRICTS
USING- ZERO COLA. FOR THE OUT
YEARS AND WHEN YOU UPDATE THAT
COAL WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND YOU DO A DEEP DIVE
ANALYSIS ON THE ENROLLMENT WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL CERTIFY
POSITIVE AGAIN- AT A SECOND
INTERIM SO WE'RE IN A
MONITORING. OF PHASE WITH A
GROW A JUST TO A NOTE FROM HIS
BEEN POSITIVE AND NORMALLY THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS A
PROGRESSIVE SYSTEM POSITED TO
QUALIFY DID NEGATIVE. ARM
TECHNICALLY THEY DON'T MEET THE
NEGATIVE OUR QUALIFICATION EVEN
THOUGH THE CERTIFIED AS SUCH
BECAUSE THEIR ISSUE IS THE
THIRD YEAR OUT OF THE THREE
YEAR WINDOW AND NEGATIVE WILL
BE RELATED TO CURRENT OR NEXT
YEAR I'M ONLY SO. WE HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT. THANK REFUSING
TO THAT LIST- I WILL TURN THE
VERY RAPIDLY- IN THEIR
REPORTING WERE RIDGE AND SACK
CITY. AYE WE ANTICIPATE WILL.
IN THEIR NEGATIVES- AT SECOND
IN OUR- IN THE CURRENT YEAR. WE
ALSO HAVE FOR LACK OF GOING
CONCERN DISTRICTS OF LACK OF
GOING CONCERN IS A TOOL THAT
BOTH THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF ADD
CAN USE. TO DESIGNATE A
DISTRICT THAT IS RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING AND THAT'S FISCAL
STABILITY. IT IS SIMILAR IN
NATURE TO A NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION ACCEPTED A
DISTRICT WOULD NOT SELF CERTIFY
ITS OFFICE MARKET GOING CONCERN
IN THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT IT
DOESN'T NEED TO DISTRICT IS
LACK OF GOING CONCERN AT ANY
TIME. DURING THE YEAR THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR AN
INTERIM REPORTING OR IT BUDGET
TALKING THEY CAN DO THAT
ANYTIME IN THEIR VIEW THAT THE
DISTRICTS FISCAL STABILITY- IS
DETERIORATING. SO FAR THIS YEAR
WE HAVE FOR LACK OF GOING
CONCERN DISTRICTS OUR UNIFIED
IN RIVERSIDE WHICH IS BEEN A
LACK OF GOING CONCERN EACH OF
THE LAST THREE YEARS.
BELLFLOWER UNIFIED IN LOS
ANGELES MONTEBELLO UNIFIED IN
LOS ANGELES IN ORDER WILL CITY
ELEMENTARY. SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
BUTTE COUNTY. AMONG THE FIFTY
ONE QUALIFIED- THAT I REPORTED
ON A FEW MOMENTS AGO IS ONE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AMONG THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
OFFICES IN THAT WOULD BE SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ITSELF CERTIFIED-
QUALIFIED. SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED ALSO SELF CERTIFIED
QUALIFIED SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY IS A- A
ONE OF OUR HANDFUL OF UNIQUE
WHERE IT'S A SINGLE DISTRICTS
SINGLE COUNTY THEY OPERATE
ALMOST AS ONE IN THE SAME. BUT
THEY HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
REPORTING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WHEN A DISTRICT MEET CERTAIN- A
CERTAIN STATUS OF MAP
AUTOMATICALLY ENGAGES IN THOSE
STATUS JUST BRIEFLY IS A
NEGATIVE BUT IT IS A
DISAPPROVED BUDGET A NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION THREE CONSECUTIVE
QUALIFIED CERTIFICATIONS A LACK
OF GOING CONCERN OR DOWNGRADE
IN THE CERTIFICATION BY THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT IF ANY OF
THOSE FIVE TRIGGERS ARE MET.
AUTOMATICALLY ENGAGES WITH THE
DISTRICT AS OPPOSED TO OUR OUR
MORE TRADITIONAL WORK WHERE WE
WAIT FOR DISTRICT TWO- CALL US
FOR ASSISTANCE ON THEREBEING
THIRTY TWO TRIGGERS OF OUR
AUTOMATIC ENGAGEMENT OVER THE
LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS- OUR
RESPONSE TO THAT AUTOMATIC
ENGAGEMENT IS THAT WE USE A
TOOL THAT WE DEVELOPED- A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND HAVE
REFINED MORE RECENTLY IN THAT
TOOLS CALLED THE FISCAL HEALTH
RISK ANALYSIS. OF
STRAIGHTFORWARD TOOLS AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEB PAGE TO DISTRICTS
CAN DOWNLOADED AND ACTUALLY DO
A SELF ASSESSMENT IF THEY WANT-
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DO IS WE COME IN AND DO. THAT-
ANALYSIS. THE RIVER OF AN- IS
TO RANK DISTRICT AS TO WHETHER
IT'S LOW RISK MAYBE MODERATE
RISK OR HIGH RISK OF FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY OR RISK OF
POTENTIAL INSOLVENCY. AND THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH- ED CODE
FORTY TWO ONE TWENTY SEVEN
POINT SIX. OF THE THIRTY TWO
TRIGGERS TWENTY THREE OR SIXTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE OF THEM HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED- WITH FIFTEEN OF
THOSE ARE 65% BE IN HIGH RISK
26% BE IN WATER RISK AND 9%
BEING LOW RISK. WE HAVE ONE IN
DRAFT WE HAVE ONE IN PROGRESS
WE HAVE ONE ON HOLD AND WE HAVE
TWO OF THOSE THIRTY TWO THAT
WOULD CANCEL. IN ADDITION AS A
RESULT OF THE DECEMBER
REPORTING WE HAVE FOR DISTRICTS
THAT WERE CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATION WITH ABOUT
STARTING THAT PROCESS BASED ON
THE REPORTING THAT THEY DID
THIS PAST DECEMBER. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT WHICH
WAS- PASSED AT THE END OF THE
FALL OF. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN-
CHANGE THE WORLD HISTORICAL WAY
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
BECOME INSOLVENT- ARE A MANAGED
OR ADMINISTERED DURING THE
PROCESS. OF PREVIOUSLY THAT
PROCESS WAS- NOT RESTED WITH
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT- R.
IT'S IT SHIFTED BACK TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE- LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
TYPE OF PHILOSOPHY AND IT
SHIFTED THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS. IN
ADDITION FOR TWO DISTRICTS IT
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
UNRESTRICTED DOLLARS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS BASED ON THEIR
FORECAST A DEFICIT. IN THE
FORECASTED DEFICIT IS SOMETHING
AFFECT MENTALITY AIDS EACH
MARCH FIRST. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR DISTRICT CITY STAFF REPORT
NOTES. ON THE HAVE OUTSTANDING.
MERCHANTS HERE PROCREATION
LOANS FROM THE FROM THE STATE
TO BAIL THEM OUT IF YOU WILL-
WHEN THEY BECAME INSOLVENT- ARM.
ONE THOSE DISTRICTS INGLE YOU
IN LOS ANGELES CA. CONTINUE TO
BE. EXTERNALLY BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE OTHER THREE
DISTRICTS OAKLAND SOUTH
MONTEREY COUNTY. JOINT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A
VALLEJO CITY. UNIFIED OF WHILE
THEY STILL HAVE OUTSTANDING
BALANCES OF THAT THEY'RE PAYING
BACK THEIR LOCAL THEIR LOCAL
CONTROL THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AUTHORITY HAS BEEN RETURNED TO
THEIR LOCAL BOARDS- FOR THOSE-
FOR THE THOSE OTHER THREE. ARE
BUT FOR INGLEWOOD IN OAKLAND AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY CALLED OUT SOME
SPECIAL. IS IT A FUNDING- AND-
FOR INGLEWOOD FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS- THAT'S BEEN A LITTLE
OVER TEN. EARLY IN DOLLARS AND
FOR OAKLAND FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS THAT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS. ARE
THESE THE PROVISIONS FOR THE
SPECIAL FUNDING- THIS MARCH
FIRST WILL BE THE LAST TIME WE
ESTIMATE THERE DEFICIT SO NEXT
YEAR NEXT FISCAL YEAR WILL BE
THE LAST YEAR THEY'LL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR- EIGHTY EIGHTY
FUNDING. ABLE WOULD ASK FRST
INTERIM ARE REPORTED A POSITIVE
CERTIFICATION AND ARE NOT
CURRENTLY FORECASTING DEFICITS
SO THERE WON'T BE. A NEED BASED
ON THAT ESTIMATE THERE WILL BE
A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN
FORTY MONEY FOR INGLEWOOD I
HAVE STAFF IN INGLEWOOD RIGHT
NOW VALIDATING ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION- AS WE GET READY TO
ISSUE OUR MARCH ONE LETTER. IN
OAKLAND ARE THEY DID FILE
QUALIFIED- INTERIM REPORT IT IS
THERE I BELIEVE SEVENTH
CONSECUTIVE QUALIFIED IN
REPORT. THEY ARE FORECASTING
THE CURRENT YEAR DEFICIT OF
AROUND THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
OUR THEY'VE NOT YET ACCOUNTED
FOR THE A ONE TIME AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY MONEY FOR THIS CURRENT
YEAR WHICH IS OVER SIXTEEN
MILLION- AND SO ONCE THEY
ACCOUNT FOR THAT THAT THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT. AS
EIGHTEEN FORTY DESIGNED IT TO
BE- WILL- GO AWAY FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR WE HAVE STAFF IN
OAKLAND RIGHT NOW A WORKING TO
LOOK AT. THEIR DEFICIT FORECAST
FOR NEXT YEAR. CONCERNS ON THE
HORIZON- WE WOULD INCLUDE- A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS IN IN THAT
LIST- SOME FOR- ACTION. BY US
IN SOME FOR US TO MONITOR.
ALONG WITH THEIR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS. FOR ACTION
WOULD BE DIXON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SOLANO COUNTY JUST
SOUTH OF SACRAMENTO- SACRAMENTO
CITY CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED
THERE AND MONITORING THAT. A
WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED IN
WEST IN- CONTRA COSTA- COUNTY
OF WOULD BE ADDITION A DISTRICT
THAT WE'RE- GETTING READY TO
ENGAGE IN. AND THEN LASTLY LOST
HILLS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR SMALL DISTRICT IN
KERN COUNTY- TO EITHER ENGAGE
YOUR MONITOR WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THAT PROCESS
OTHER LOSING ENROLLMENT AS
WELL. AS THEIR NEIGHBOR BELL
RIDGE. TO A CHARTER SCHOOL-
ADDRESS SOLVENCY. YOU'VE HEARD
THESE THEMES ALREADY VAST
QUESTIONS AROUND THESE THINGS
THIS MORNING- SO WILL CERTAINLY
IDENTIFY WHAT WE SEE OUT THERE
AS WE WORK WITH DISTRICTS THAT.
ARE EXPERIENCING DISTRESS OR
JUST WORK WITH THEM TO ASSIST
THEM IN SOME WAY. THE FIRST IS
TO NOTE THAT RESERVES ARE
GENERALLY I'M HIGHER THAN THEY
WERE AT THIS POINT IN THE GREAT-RECESSION JOBS DISTRICTS
ENTERED INTO THE PANDEMIC AND
THE INITIAL FORECAST LAST
SPRING OF- A TOUGH ECONOMIC
TIMES AHEAD DUE TO A PANDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION. DISTRICTS
ENTERED INTO THAT PERIOD- WAS
MUCH STRONGER RESERVES THAN
THEY DID IN- SEVEN AWAIT AS WE
ENTERED THE GREAT RECESSION.
AND BASED ON RECENT ANALYSIS
WORK THAT THE ALI I. WAS DONE
IN IN- THEY CAN SPEAK TO THE
APP THEMSELVES- IT WOULD APPEAR
THAT THOSE RESERVES ARE I'M
CONTINUE TO BE STRONG IN THE
EARLY PART. OF THE PANDEMIC. TO
HELP CARRY THEM THROUGH THE
CURRENT YEAR- AND POSITION THEM
WELL I'M GOING FORWARD. MULTI
YEAR PROJECTIONS IN MANY
DISTRICTS TO SHOW DEFICIT
TRENDS- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
REASONS FOR THAT- BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL SIX
SPECIALLY WITH THE- TWO YEAR
COMPOUNDED CALL OF THREE POINT
EIGHT NINE. THAT ESTIMATE WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE ELEMENT OF A
MOVING FROM A ZERO CALL OUT TO
A FUNDED COLA AND- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REALLY- ACCOUNT FOR BOTH YEARS
THE CURRENT YEAR AND NEXT YEAR.
WILL PROBABLY TURN 2230% OF OUR
FIFTY ONE QUALIFIES BACK TO A
POSITIVE BASED ON OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS. WE KNOWTHAT IT WILL
TURN AS I'VE ALREADY ALLUDED TO
ONE NEGATIVE IN THAT'S ALL
GROWTH. BACK TO A POSITIVE
ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS
THAT THEY'RE DOING ON THEIR
ENROLLMENT TRENDS- THE MOST
FREQUENT CONDITION AMONG
QUALIFIED CERTIFICATIONS IS
THAT OF DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
ABOUT 60% OF CALIFORNIA'S K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT OF THIS STARTED PRE
PANDEMICS BEEN GOING ON FOR
SEVERAL YEARS ARE WE CLEARLY
SEE JUMPS IN. ESCALATION IN
MEDICAL DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR A
PREDOMINATELY A VERY EARLY
GRADES- TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND KINDERGARTEN
WHERE WE'RE GUESSING MOST. MANY
FAMILIES ELECTED TO KEEP THEIR
YOUNGEST KIDS HOME AND NOT BE
ENGAGED IN DISTANCE LEARNING.
THAT DATA ACROSS THE STATE IS-
JUST BEING COLLECTED AND
CERTIFIED- IN FINAL FORM THIS
WEEK ARMAND SO THAT'LL BE DATA
THAT'LL BE AVAILABLE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- IN THE COMING
MONTHS. SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS
IN IN THE FACT THAT SPECIAL ED
COSTS OUTPACE SPECIAL AND
REVENUE- ALSO IS A VERY COMMON
THEME NUMBER ONE IS COMMON
THING PROBABLY AND MOST IN
ALMOST EVERY DISTRICT BUT FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING DISTRESS
THAT GAP- IS NOTED ON MOST
DISTRICTS IN DISTRESS HAVE
HIGHER LEVELS OF LOCAL
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO SPECIAL ED
PROGRAMS AND SOME OTHER
DISTRICTS AND THEN FINALLY AS
HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO A NUMBER OF
TIMES THIS MORNING EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION RATES TO THE TO
PENSION SYSTEMS THAT SERVE OUR
K. FOURTEEN INSTITUTIONS AND
THAT'S CASTERS IN CALPERS. ON
AND REALLY THE CURRENT
PROJECTED INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WHEN THE
TEMPORARY RELIEF THAT WAS
PROVIDED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THIS YEAR- AND FOR NEXT YEAR
EXPIRES THE L. A- SPOKE TO THIS
AND THEIR SUGGESTION TO
POTENTIALLY. PUT MORE DOLLARS
INTO THIS TOPIC TO SLOW THAT
THE INCREASE IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AS WE LOOK OUT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IS
GOING TO BE A VERY DIFFICULT
YEAR A NUMBER ONE WE HAVE- A
SLOWING YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH
PROJECTED- ARMENIAN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
THE IMPACTS OF THE VARIOUS
EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS THE SPECIAL ONES
ENACTED THIS YEAR DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC THE TRADITIONAL ONES
THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO RETURN
NEXT YEAR SO FOR DECLINING
ENROLLMENT DISTRICT THEIR
REVENUES HAVE BEEN HELD
HARMLESS THIS YEAR AND WILL BE
HELD HARMLESS AGAIN NEXT YEAR-
HOWEVER THAT ALL WILL CATCH UP
TO THEM. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ON IN THE WORLD AT THAT
POINT THERE REVENUES WILL BE
IMPACTED BY- AN EXTREMELY A
DECLINING AND- IN. WITH RESPECT
AUDIT- THESE ARE THE AUTO SAID
WERE CALLED UPON BY CAN
SUPERINTENDENT- TO DO- OUR
ACTIVITY AT THIS POINT IS DOWN
ARE FROM NOR ARE WE HAVE A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF OUR STAFF
DEDICATED TO ONE PARTICULAR
AUDIT I'M IN THAT IS A- THE
NETWORK A NETWORK OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE'RE LOOKING AT EIGHT
AMONG THE- THAT NETWORK OF FOR
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS OUT OF
SAN DIEGO. COUNTY THERE ARE IN
MULTIPLE COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND AGAIN WE HAVE EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT HAVE ASKED US TO
JOINTLY ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THIS- THIS PARTICULAR CHARTER
SCHOOL NETWORK WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT AUDIT PROCESS
DOING TRANSACTION TESTING. ALL
RIGHT NOW. ADJUSTED LOOK YEAH
COMMITTEE. ARE REALIZED THE
FOCUS YEARS K. TWELVE BUT- WITH
RESPECT TO FITNESS WORK- WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LASSEN IN LASSEN
COUNTY. PALOMAR IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND PERALTA IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE'VE ISSUED REPORTS
INVOLVE PERALTA AND PALOMAR A
PREVIOUSLY. ARM LASSEN WE HAVE
ISSUED ONE REPORT AND AS OF
THIS MORNING WE'RE ACTUALLY
SAYS- HOUSING OR GAUGE WITH
THEIR OF THAT PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS NOT FULLY
COOPERATING. WITH US AND SO THE
CHANCELLOR NEEDS TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL DIRECTION. WE ALSO
ON OUR WATCH LIST HAVE A CITY
COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF KIND OF
IN AND OUT OF- AJ. STRESSFUL
TIMES FISCALLY. ON IN WE'RE
CURRENTLY- THEY'RE CURRENTLY ON
OUR WATCH LIST. WITHOUT MISTER
CHAIR I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THEY'LL DEFER.
ANYTHING YOU'D WANT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I HAVE A BRIEF
COMMENT A COUPLE OF. IN MY
BRIEF COMMENT IS IT WAS
INTERESTING TO SEE YOUR CHART
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE THE FIRST TIME AND
IT HAS BEEN TWELVE YEARS SINCE
I LEFT. WE HAD SOME BIG-
PROBLEMS AND NOW I SEE THEM ON
YOUR CHART BEING NEAR THE END
OF THEIR LONG PAYMENT WHETHER
IT WAS THE- OAKLAND SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR THE VALLEJO SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND- AND- I'M PROBABLY
THE ONLY PERSON IN THE
LEGISLATURE THE WENT K. THROUGH
TWELVE IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND VALLEJO SO HIGH. WATCH THAT
VERY CLOSELY. ARM TWO QUESTIONS
IN ONE JUST CAME UP FOR ME AT
THE END OF YOUR- OUR COMMENTS.
WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN OUR-
SOMEBODY DOES NOT COOPERATE
WITH YOU ON AN AUDIT. AND YU
JUST MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS A
CASE WHERE THAT WAS HAPPENING
WHAT WHAT HOW DO YOU PROCEED TO
TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
WELL IN IN IN THIS PARTICULAR
REFERENCES I WOULDN'T DESCRIBE
IS AN HONOR WERE THERE TO
ASSIST THE AS OPPOSED TO
ACTUALLY AUDITING AND SO WERE
THERE TO LOOK- WE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN LASSEN ON THEIR
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT. PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOSING A
SIGNIFICANT ENROLLMENT. IN
LOOKING AT THAT AND THEN THERE
WAS A NUMBER OF TASKS THE
CHANCELLOR ASKED JUST TO LOOK
AT CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ACCESS
TO LOOK AT SOARED TAKEN KIND OF
ONE BY ONE- WHAT. WERE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE WE'RE GONNA
PAUSE- AND RE ENGAGE WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE-
THE COLLEGE ITSELF AND MAKE
SURE THE- BODY THEY WANT US TO
CONTINUE TO BE THERE AND IF
THEY DO THEN WILL. WILL RETURN
AND CONTINUE TO PLUG ON- MOST.
WEIGHT WHEN A DISTRICT WHETHER
TO K. TWELVE OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVING FISCAL DISTRESS
ARE LOOKING FOR ASSISTANCE AND
WE'RE JUST. WE'RE PART OF THAT-
INTERVENTION PROCESS THAT THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT CAN CALL
UPON. TO HELP WOMEN IN MOST
CASES. THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
LET'S SAY IN THE COUNTY OFFICER
EXACTLY ON THE SAME PAGE. THEY
ARE MOVING FORWARD TOGETHER
THEY HAVE AN INTERESTING
QUICKLY TURNING- THE DISTRICT
AROUND. FROM A FINANCIAL SYSTEM
STABILITY STANDPOINT INSTAGRAM
EVERYBODY'S WORKING ON. THE
SAME NOTE THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL I.
ALL HAVE ROLES AND THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF QUAN. WE
DO X. PERIODS WHERE- THERE'S A
LACK OF COOPERATION- AND THOSE
ARE VERY VERY DIFFICULT- TASK
TO DO WE DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. TO JUST GO IN AND DO
X. Y. Z. AND HELP THEM STRONG
SUPERINTENDENTS MAY HAVE SOME
LIMITED AUTHORITY IN THAT WORK
IN THAT REGARD- BUT THOSE ARE
DIFFICULT WHEN WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED SEVERAL OF THOSE IN
THIS PAST YEAR- MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WANT ME TO USE AN ANALOGY
THAT. THAT I THINK MOST OF US
ARE FAMILIAR WITH NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
GAUGED IN ABOUT JUST BECAUSE
WERE KNOWLEDGEABLE. AND THAT'S
A TWELVE STEP PROCESS TO HELP
SOMEBODY WITH A- INDEED SEE ON
ON ALCOHOL LET'S SAY- IT REALLY
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT AUTHOR WHAT
THE TWELVE STEP PROGRAM YOU'RE
USING STEP NUMBER ONE IS ALWAYS
THE SAME. AND THAT'S TOOK
KNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE A PROBLEM I
USE THAT SAME ANALOGY WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN FISCAL
DISTRESS- DISTRICTS WITH
CHARACTERISTICS- THAT LEND
THEMSELVES TO. TURNING THAT
DISTRESS AROUND IMMEDIATELY AND
STABILIZING THE VERY FIRST
THING THEY DO IS THEY KNOWLEDGE
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM. AND THAT'S
OFTEN WHEN THEY REACH OUT TO US
ORIGINALLY ORDERED THEIR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT REACHES OUT TO
US FOR ASSISTANCE- BUT
SOMETIMES THEY ADVANCED TO THE
ANGER STEP BEFORE THEY- START
WITH THE ACKNOWLEDGING THE
PROBLEM STUFF. FOLLOW- LEAVE
I'LL LEAVE THAT OUT BUT YES
THERE'S SOME SOME INTERNAL.
DISCUSSION IN ANNA. AND SOLDER
AND WELL I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION AND I THINK YOU
ANSWERED IT BUT LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE. OF BECAUSE YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE COLA
REALLY MOST PEOPLE. ARE OUT OF
CERTAIN SIR THREATEN TO SPACE.
ARE ARE YOU SEEING ANYTHING
THAT IS SORT OF SPECIFIC COMING
OUT OF COVERED AND- PANDEMIC
THAT IS. CAUSING YOU TO HAVE
ALERTS ABOUT CERTAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WELL CERTAINLY THE
PANDEMIC- PRESENTS ITSELF AS
YOU AWFULLY APPRECIATE US SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES ARE IN
MANY RESPECTS WHY WE THOUGHT
THE PANDEMIC WAS GOING TO
PRESENT. A KIND OF EQUAL
CHALLENGES AROUND FINANCE AND
FISCAL STABILITY IN OPERATIONS-
SPECIFICALLY TEACHING
OPERATIONS ARM THE REALITY IS
THIS WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE A
DIFFICULT BUDGET THIS YEAR WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A VERY. POSITIVE
BUDGETS OF THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED
FOR NEXT YEAR SO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE A BUDGET
PROBLEM PER SE THAT WE WERE
EXPECTING THIS YEAR. AND NEXT
YEAR THINGS- AS YOU KNOW
REVENUES- HAVE NOT FOLLOWED THE
FORECAST- IN HAVE BEEN MUCH
IMPROVED SO THEY'RE REAL
THEY'RE REAL CHALLENGES ARE
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES-
SPECIFICALLY TEACHING HI MY
WIFE IS AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER SO SHE'S BEEN RIGHT
HERE. WITH ME IN OUR HOME
OFFICE- SINCE MARCH. THIRTEENTH
OF LAST SPRING- OUR SON IS IN
HIS FIRST YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHING THIS YEAR ALL DOING IT
VIRTUALLY I WOULD NOT WANT TO
BE A NEW TEACHER STARTING OUT
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT- THOSE ARE
THE REAL CHALLENGES IN YES THEY
ARE FISCAL. ISSUES RELATED TO
THOSE THE IN PERSON RETURNING
THE IN PERSON AS YOU NOW ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TO MEET
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES-
DURING THE DISTANCE LEARNING
CERTAINLY THE CHALLENGES AROUND
THE TECHNOLOGY DIVIDE. ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT SPOKE TO IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SPOKEN TO- TO
SUPPORT DISTANCE LEARNING- A
LOT. OF SUNLIGHT I THINK THAT'S
REALLY HELPFUL WITH OMINOUS
SENATOR MENIFEE. HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION- I HAD A BUNCH BEFORE
YOU STARTED YOU ANSWERED ALMOST
ALL OF THEM WHICH IS A- I THINK
A TESTAMENT TO YOUR THOROUGH-
PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE THAT-
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND. WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
CORRECTLY YOU WERE. DISCUSSING
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD DO IS
LONGER TERM STRUCTURAL ISSUES
WITH SOME OF THESE DISTRESSED
DISTRICTS. OR DISTRESS COOLS
AND VERBES WOULD BE SOME OF THE
CALL VISIT DRIVEN- CAUSES THE
DESTRUCTION I THINK WHAT YOU
SAID IS THAT AMONG THE LONGER
TERM STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS. WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING. AT- THREE
ISSUES DECLINING ENROLLMENT. IS
SPECIAL ED AND- SPECIAL AND
REVENUE AND AT PENSION FUNDING.
IS THAT A CORRECT SUMMARY OF
WHAT YOU STATED IT ASSUMING WE
GET OUT OF COVER THOSE IN THE
LONGER TERM ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING. ABSOLUTELY SIR THOSE
THOSE ARE THE THREE OF. OUR
PREVAILING CONSISTENT ELEMENTS
IN MOST OF THE DISTRICTS
REPORTING A QUALIFIED RIGHT NOW
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO
THAT- IN THIS IS SCOTT BOTH THE
GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS ASPECT
TO IT. AND THAT IS THAT THE ONE
TIME NATURE FUNDING RIGHT ALL
DOLLARS ARE IMPORTANT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHIN THEIR
RECURRING OR THERE ONE TIME THE
ONE TIME PRESENTS CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY WHEN. THE NEED THAT
THEY'RE ADDRESSING MAY GO
BEYOND THE TIME PERIOD AND YOU
HEARD THAT ALREADY FROM THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE AUDIO AND
FINANCE. A TODAY IN THEIR
PROPOSALS- AND SO THAT'S THE
ONE ELEMENT THAT I WENT OUT TO
THE HOUSE THAT'S A DIFFICULT
PLANNING EFFORT FOR DISTRICTS.
TO THEIR COMMUNITY THEY'VE GOT
A TREMENDOUS MORE RESOURCES IN
YET THEY'RE STILL REPORTING
DISTRESS. AND SO THERE'S A
COMMUNICATION ISSUE THEIR
UNDERSTANDING BY THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THERE'S THEIR
BROADER STAKEHOLDERS- OF THEIR
CONDITIONS. THANK YOU WITH US A
LOT OF FOOD FOR THOUGHT I
APPRECIATE. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER FINE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU SIR. ARM NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD AND FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE. AND IT IS TO
REMIND YOU THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. SEVEN SIX
OH NINE. PRO DUTERTE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LIKES
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. OF THE CHAIR MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY A MAN ASK EACH
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. PROVIDING
COMMENT TO KEEP THEIR REMARKS
TO WITHIN ONE MINUTE. AND ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANYBODY THAT'S
DESTRUCTIVE MAY. BE REMOVED OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECT IN MUTED AND
WANT TO PLEASE NOTE THAT IF.
ARE IN THIS WHERE YOU'RE- A
CALLING IN IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO A QUIET
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. ABOUT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. SO
WITH THAT- LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN THIS HEARING ROOM. DOES
ANYBODY WISH TO OFFER A COMMON.
CAN I INTRODUCE YOU FOR YOU. MY
AXLES IF YOU WOULD PLEASE BE
NEXT TO THE MICROPHONE YOU TALK
SO THAT WE CAN. I'M COMING YOUR
PERSONAL ATTITUDE NO BUT SHE
WAS TALKING TO I KNOW MANY
WONDER DOING PLEASE YOU HAVE A
MINUTE PLEASE- BEGIN THANK YOU
VERY MY NAME IS RAVEN JOHN. I'M
A REGISTERED NURSE IN
SACRAMENTO I'VE BEEN A
REGISTERED NURSE PROBABLY FOR
SOME OF YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS. I HAVE
ENERGY I HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
PEDIATRIC CRITICAL CARE I
HAVEN'T BACKGROUND IN EDUCATION
AND RESEARCH I AM CURRENTLY A
GERIATRIC AND HOSPICE EXPERT. I
DEAL WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DYING OF COLD AIR
EVERY SINGLE DAY THERE EIGHTY
FIVE YEARS OLD THEY HAVE HEART
DISEASE THEY HAVE KIDNEY
DISEASE THEY HAVE LIVER
DISEASE. THIS SIX YEAR OLDS ARE
NOT FIX MY THIRTEEN YEAR OLD IS
NOT AT RISK YOU ALL ARE NOT AT
RISK YOU ARE CRUMBLING
CALIFORNIA BY KEEPING THESE
KIDS AT HOME SHAME ON YOU.
SHAME ON YOU FOR DESTROYING
THIS STATE BY DESTROYING THESE
CHILDREN. THERE IS NO ELEVEN
YEAR OLD DOWN THIS FROM MY
HOUSE WHO IS NOW DEAD. HE SHOT
HIMSELF IN THE CHEST DURING IS
THE MEETING. HIS SIX YEAR OLD
SISTER WAS IN THE NEXT ROOM HIS
SINGLE MOTHER WITHOUT LOOKING
FOR WORK WHILE YOU'RE IN HERE
TALKING ABOUT YOUR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
THE- AT HOME WE- YOUR COMMENTS.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
THAT IS A MINUTE TO ADD A NEXT
SPEAKER. I AGREE WITH. THANKS
VERY VERY OH MY GOD I DON'T
KNOW WHY I KEEP COMING BACK WHY
DO I KEEP COMING BACK. WHY DO I
KEEP COMING BACK THERE IS A
PROVERB THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
DOG RETURNING TO THE VOMIT. HI
MUST BE THAT DOG. THIS HEARING
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH CHILDREN
AND I SAY THAT AS THE WIFE OF A
CREDENTIALED PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER. I HAVE FOUR CHILDREN.
YOU ARE KILLING CALIFORNIA YOU
ARE KILLING THE CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THIS LOCKDOWN.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE THIS
HEARING HAD TO DO WITH THE
UNIONS MEANWHILE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE SEEN ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN THIS ENROLL JUST SINCE
THIS PANDEMIC THERE IS NO RISK
FOR CHILDREN AND NOW YOU HAVE
LA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND OTHER
TEACHER AND USE UNIONS STRONG
ARMING. PARENTS INTO TAKING THE
CALL THE SHOT THEIR KID THAT'S
A MINUTE THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A
COMMENT. THEN SINGING NINE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THAT WISHES TO OFFER
A COMMENT. SEEING NO ONE. ARE
MOVING TO THE PODIUM IN THAT
ROOM THEN NOW WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE A MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
MIGHT BE WAITING TO PROVIDE.
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WOULD BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WHAT
WHAT THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE PLEASE CALL HAS. HELLO
AIR NAPPY WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
I THINK CONSIDER EARLY ACTION
ON EXPANDED LEARNING ACADEMIC
INTERVENTION GRANT WE URGE YOU
TO KEEP EQUITY FOREMOST IN
MIND. AND DEMOCRATS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED HIGH
NEED STUDENTS WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY UNDER REPORT AND
YOU INVESTMENT MUST PRIORITIZE
THEIR NEEDS TO CLOSE WIDENING
OPPORTUNITY GAP. TO ENSURE THAT
INVESTMENTS FOR EXTENDED
LEARNING AND SUPPORT BENEFIT
THE MOST IMPACTED STUDENTS
FUNDING SHOULD BE ALLOCATED
BALLY EIGHT IN PROPORTION TO
THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION FUNDING. EXPANDED
ANY PROGRAM SHOULD ENSURE A
TRULY RESTORATIVE RETURNED TO
SCHOOL I CENTER IN QUALITY OVER
QUANTITY IN POVIDING
INNOVATIVE ACADEMIC AND
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES. AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING FUNDS
ALLEY IT SHOULD ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE SHEELER
CULTURALLY AFFIRMING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. TO ADDRESS STUDENT
TRAUMA. COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
THE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT MUST
ALSO BE PRIORITIZE VALUE SHOULD
LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING EXPANDED
LEARNING SYSTEM AND BE REQUIRED
TO ENGAGE IN REMEMBER LOCAL
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. IN PLANNING
A FACILITATING EXTENDED
LEARNING AND SUMMER PROGRAM.
LASTLY WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE
THESE MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
AGAIN THIS WILL NEED ONGOING
FEELERS SUPPORT WE RECOVER FROM
KOBE NINETEEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARM.
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHT TWENTY GO AHEAD.
I WAS MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE
AFTER CALIFORNIA ORDERS THIS
APPRECIATE THE- IF THE
ADMINISTRATION SPOKE ON THE
LOTS MANY GAY. AND WE WOULD
ALSO JUST LIKE TO- TAKE MAYBE
AND THE L. A. L. FOR THEIR
COMMENTS ABOUT- PAID BACK THE
PEARLS WE WOULD AGREE. THAT WE
THINK A 100% OF- OF PAPERBACK
THE DEFERRAL SHOULD BE
HAPPENING THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BILL IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THAT BOY THE
BUDGET IS INCOMPLETE IT TURNED
OUT HE DID NOT HE CAN DO
ACCOUNT ALREADY PREPAID OPEN
FOR DIRECT SCHOOL SUPPORT
FINDING THE ONE NUMBER. THESE
BONDS AUTHORIZED FOR USE FOR
MUCH OF WHAT IS BEING REQUESTED
FOR THE TWO BILLION FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION PROPOSED EXPANSION
PLANS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE RECONCILE ALL MEET
THAT OPENS FIRST. WITH THE NEW
UNEXPECTED GENERAL FUND
REVENUES AND THEN MAY TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO UNDO ALL
THE PHONE ISSUE- INDICATED WILL
DO ALL IT CAN TO AVOID
DIFFICULT GOING INTO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SHIFTING ST CASH
MANAGEMENT PARTY'S TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO BASKETBALL WHILE
INTEREST. YOUR DEFERRALS MAY
HAVE SOME RATIONAL CROSS HERE
TO BUILD THE NOT FEDERAL TAX
EXEMPTION FOR TO BUILD A YEAR
AWAY THE RED HERRING
MAINTAINING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN COSTS YOU TO PRODUCE LAW
HAVING A PART BECAUSE OF AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS- BUDGET GYMNASTICS. IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO SHORT SCHOOLS
NOW PLAN THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION OF CUTS IN THE FUTURE
WHEN SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY GOING
TO FACE INCREASED COSTS FOR
PENSIONS. PROJECT INVOLVING THE
IN YEAR TWO AND THREE AS YOU.
JUST HEARD. YOU HEARD ALSO
REALLY THIS COST YOU TO. THE
BALL. THREE TO SEVEN. PER WEEKS
COFFEE TABLE BOOKS. BILL SIR
ARE YOUR- MISS. BE ADAM. SO ME
FOR YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
PERSIAN OUR NEXT CALL MY- THANK
YOU FIFTEEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE CHANGE ROCKS ON
PROVIDING COM I'M BECAME BE
HEALTH DIRECTORS. OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CALL AND OF
THE TWO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IMPROPER THIS NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY TO
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. RIGHT SCHOOL
BASED SERVICES- THIS COMING BE
PER TO ELEAZAR WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
EXPECTED TO MATCH THE FUNDING
WITH COUNTY. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT SPENDING PLANS
MEDICARE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS ORDER RECENT
SURVEY AND SHE BEACH GAVE
MEMBERS 87% OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
ALREADY PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON SCHOOL SITE. WITH
FIFTY FOUR PROVIDING SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT ON
SCHOOL SITES. CONDITIONALLY 69%
OF COUNTY NEIGHBOR HELP
AGENCIES WITH IMAGE STATE BANK
PROVIDES SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
WITH SOME COUNTY AND SCHOOLS
ALREADY COMBINING IMAGES STATE
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL RESOURCE IS.
INSURING CHILDREN AND YOU CAN
PAY FOR HEALTH SERVICES THEY
NEED. THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATION WILL HELP
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE AND
THINGS CRITICAL PARTNERSHIP THE
LONG TERM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK
YOU TWENTY ONE CALL AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING BEEN NATIONALLY HALF OF
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN THE CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY EXCELLENCE CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE FIVE EXTENDED
LEARNING TO GET CRITICAL AND
ACADEMIC EMOTIONAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS WHO NEED
IT MOST THAT COULD BE AFFECTED
IF POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT THE SUIT
RECOVERY EXPECTED DURING
PROVISIONS OUTLINED AB ONE OF
FOUR BY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS. A
SPECIFICALLY WE URGE YOU TO
LEVERAGE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
SYSTEM A PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTERSCHOOL AND SUMMER LEARNING
PROGRAMS AND EXPANDED LEARNING
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT DROPPED STATE
THEY HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
WORKING FAMILIES HAVE BEEN HIT
HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC AND IBM
DESTRUCTION TO BE ENGAGE
STUDENTS FOR ACADEMIC RECOVERY
AND CARE FOR THE NEEDS OF THE
WHOLE CHILD. CITY HELP URGENTLY
AND INEFFECTIVE USE OF LIMITED
RESOURCES TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL. AND FINALLY INVESTMENT
SHOULD BE MADE IN EVIDENCE
BASED LEARNING SPORTS. AND
ELEAZAR PLANNER. REUTERS SENATE
LEARNING PROGRAM LEVERAGE AND
ENGAGE LEARNING UP. THAT CREATE
A THE GLAND I CAN SUPPORTS.
ENRICHMENT AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL.
THANK YOU PARTNERS HAVE A-
RELATIONSHIPS WITH. TO READ TO
THE- AND WORK WITH EACH BY
SUPPORT- COMPANY WILL BE. FOR
ME STRIDES WITH TO THIS ISSUE
AND THOMAS TO HAVE EXTRA. I'M
LISA THE LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE IRAQ. SIR HERE YOUR
JUST OVER- WE- YOUR COMMENTS
AND ONE THAT YOU SUBMITTED
LETTER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU TWENTY TWO GO OUT.
YES MANY IS ROCHELLE CALL AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
DISGUSTED I AM AT HEARING. YOU
GUYS DISCUSSED ONLY FINANCES
WHENEVER NO ONE HEARD ANYTHING
ABOUT ANY GOOD FOR THE CHILDREN
OR ANY CASES OR ANY HEALTH
EFFECTS OR ANYTHING ALL WE
HEARD ABOUT WITH MONEY
MANAGEMENT. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
YOU THAT ALL OF YOU TODAY ARE
GOING TO BE HELD RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE DAMAGE THAT YOU'RE.
GOING TO DO FOR SIX. RIGHT WILL
BE GENOCIDE. YOU CAN BUT WE-
YOURSELF WOULD BE OUR WHEN
YOU'RE DON'T. EVEN BACK. BEING
HEY ON THE INSERT ARE NOT EVEN
JILL UNDER THE AGE OF. YEAH
GUYS ARE TO BE A WITH FORCING
THEM ON THE YOU MAKE THEM GO
BACK TO SCHOOL. ALL WILL BE BY
YOU'RE ALL PUT ON AS IF YOU.
THANK YOU IT'S WILL BE AND YOUR
WALLET BE BETTER BECAUSE. THREE
THREE OH OF SCHOOLS AND YOU
KNOW FORCED. EXACT THIS BACK
WHICH IS. A BIT OF MANY. YOU'RE
A BIT OF MINUTES THANK YOU MUCH
YOUR CALL MY- NEXT. HOW THANK
RIGHT EIGHT GOING. HI KATIE
WITH CALIBER TEACHERS DESPITE
THE- WE APPRECIATE AND IN BACK.
AND POOR AND YOU IN IN THE BY
REGARDING THAT YOU BILLION FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION WE SHARED
WITH YOU SOME OF OUR CONCERN
BUDGET HIGHLIGHTS THAT YOU KNOW
ALL THE PIZZA PORTRAYAL
BACKTESTING- WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABUSING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FOR THIS PURPOSE AND
ADDITIONALLY REGARDING PROP
NINETY EIGHT WE APPRECIATE THAT
TWO POINT THREE BILLION ONE HI
SACRAMENTO PAYMENT AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN A LONG
TERM COMMITMENT INCREASE. AND
THE POP NINETY LEVEL I'M
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
I THINK YOU AND. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE PER
YOUR- OF MODERATOR NEXT KOHLER.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CURRENTLY PAYING WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE WERE
STATEWIDE YOU OUR ORGANIZATION
FIGHTING FOR RACIAL JUSTICE I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
INVESTMENT IN HEALTH AND
WELLBEING THE TYPICALLY
COMMUNICORP AT THE HELP THE
POINTS BEHIND THIRD BASE- BUT
OFTEN WANT TO LIFT UP A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT- AND THE NEED TO
HAVE TARGETED PLAN FOR HIGH
SCHOOL JUNIORS AND SENIORS
GREAT RISK OR NOT OR AT RISK OF
NOT GRADUATING. WE FEEL LIKE
THE INTERNET AND ONE POINT IN
THEIR EDUCATION WITHOUT MAKE
QUITE THE DRAW ON HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WORK AND HE'S
CRITICAL YEARS THAT THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES FUTURE CHILDREN
UNDERSCORED OPPORTUNITY OR
SCORED A PRISONER POPPY
PIPELINE- WE WANT FOLKS THINK
ABOUT RESPONDING TO THE ISSUE
BY REPORTING TRACKING AND
PLANNING TARGET WHAT THE
RESOURCES. FOR THE YOUNG FOLKS
AND AGAIN I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN- IN A
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION WITH THEM-
THAT THE DOLLAR. STUDENTS THAT
THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR CALLER. THANK YOU
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO- THIS ASSEMBLY HERE
FINALLY THREE OPEN SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED AND WE'RE CALLING- WE
WANTED TO FIND OUT IF YOU MIGHT
HAVE CONSIDERED ANYTHING MAYBE
MORE CREATIVE WITH HOLD
HARMLESS- BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS THAT THAT IS.
PREVENTING FOOD DISTRICTS FROM
HAVING ANY INCENTIVE OF WORKING
WITH PARENTS AND IF YOU'RE NOT
MAYBE A PORTION OF THE EXTRA
STUDENTS THAT ARE NO LONGER
ATTENDING. HI FROM OUT OF THE
OPENING IF NOT IS THERE A WAY
TO AT LEAST LINE ITEM HOW MUCH
EXTRA MONEY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO HOLD HARMLESS A THREE
STUDENTS THEY ARE NO LONGER
TEACHING. BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES IT'S MORE THAN THE CARE
ACT ITSELF AND THEN SECONDLY
REGARDING CARE ACT WE'RE REALLY
HAVING A HARD TIME FINDING
WHERE THIS MONEY'S GOING WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MUCH MORE
GRANULAR REPORTING DOWN TO THE
ACTUAL PROGRAM THAT IS BEING
FUNDED BY THE FUNDS THE L. C.
T. IS WAY TOO VAGUE. AND IT IS
REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW WHERE
THE FUNDS ARE GOING BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT SEEING IT AT THE
STUDENT LEVEL IN OUR DISTRICT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE WE TRADITIONALLY DON'T
RESPOND TO A TWO COMMENTS BUT
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THAT ALL
THINGS ARE ON THE TABLE OF
NEGOTIATIONS A MODERATOR. NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU AYE NIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
DANTE FOWLER DIRECTOR PROGRAMS
WOODCRAFT RANGERS. I'M A FORMER
ALUMNI AND EXPAND THE LEARNING
THAT I WORKED WITH THE
ORGANIZATION FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS LIKE LIKE WHAT CRAP
READERS- WE SERVE LOW INCOME
CHILDREN FROM COMMUNITIES OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED- BY
COLBY THE CHILDREN WE SERVE
HAVE COMPLEX NEEDS ALREADY DUE
TO POVERTY AND UNDER RESOURCE
SCHOOLS BUT NOW WITH THE TRAUMA
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED IN THE
LAST YEAR WE CAN RESOURCES
THREE ACCLIMATE THEM AND HELP
THEM HEAL. YOUNG PEOPLE AGAIN
BY PRIORITIZING THEIR SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS IT LOOKS
LIKE WE FOUND THE LEARNING
PROVIDER DURING NORMAL TIMES WE
PROVIDE ACTIVITY THAT KIDS LOVE
LIKE PARKER FAN MONEY OUT YOUNG
ROBOT. AND WILL BE MOST AND I
DO LIKE IF YOU FIRST TIME
KIDNAP ABOUT TO GO OUT AND PLAY.
WE YOU TO EXISTING THE GRANT
IMPRESSED AT ONE PRIORITIES
COMMUNITIES- THAT HAVE HIT
HARDEST BY THE AND THEN AND WE
HAVE STAFF THAT ARE GOAL- I
WORK A LOT STATE BUT THE
FOLLOWING PRODUCTS THEM FROM
THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT IT WILL
WILL NEED AUG TWENTY FIFTH
APPLE QUICKLY FOR A PROGRAMS.
BE ABLE TO START THE YOU WE
APPRECIATE THE COMING YOUR JUST
OF OVER SO THANK YOU YOUR COM
WE PER YOUR A MODERATOR NEXT A
CALL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO.
COMMENTS ON THE PHONE. MORE
THAN SEEING. OF WILL IT BACK TO
HEAR WE WE'VE HEARD ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND- AND WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INTO WHO PUT. IN
THE PUBLIC TEST TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT A TO TOUCH TODAY YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW SUB
COMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. ARE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS IN SO THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION SENATOR MEN DO
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
HE HAS NONE SO THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION SOTHIS CONCLUDES
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
OF THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
IS A JERK.